welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Dr Robert
lustig Dr Robert lustig is an
endocrinologist that is he's a
specialist in the function of hormones
in the body and a professor of Pediatric
Endocrinology at the University of
California San Francisco he has authored
more than 100 peer-reviewed studies
exploring how different types of
nutrients that is food impact our
cellular functioning our organ
functioning and thereby our health
during today's discussion we discussed
the idea of whether or not a calorie is
indeed a calorie and whether or not our
body weight and body composition only
reflects the number of calories we eat
versus the calories that we burn we talk
about how different food types that is
how the different macronutrients protein
fat and carbohydrates are processed in
the body and the important role that
fiber and the gut microbiome plays in
that process and we pay particular
attention to the topic of how different
types of sugars and fructose in
particular can indeed be addictive to
the brain and can modify the way that
hormones in the body in particular
insulin impact our Liver Health Kidney
Health and indeed the health of all of
our cells and organs indeed Dr lustig is
an expert in how sugar impacts the brain
and body we talk about how certain types
of sugars can indeed be addictive in the
same way that certain drugs of abuse and
behaviors can become addictive so in
other words how sugar actually changes
the way that the brain works and we
discuss how the food industry that is
the commoditization and sale of
particular types of food has altered the
way that we eat and indeed the foods
that We crave today's discussion covers
all of that and by the end of today's
discussion you'll have a thorough
understanding of how foods are processed
when they enter your body and how those
different food choices are impacting
your immediate and long-term Health
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is eight sleep eight
sleep makes Smart mattress covers with
cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
in this podcast about the fact that
sleep is the foundation of Mental Health
physical health and performance now a
key component of getting a great night's
sleep is that in order to fall and stay
deeply asleep your body temperature
actually has to drop by about 1 to 3
degre and in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized your body
temperature actually has to increase by
about 1 to 3° one of the best ways to
make sure that those temperature changes
occur at the appropriate times at the
beginning and throughout and at the end
of your night when you wake up is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's what eight sleep
allows you to do it allows you to
program the temperature of your mattress
and sleeping environment such that you
fall and stay deeply asleep easily and
wake up each morning feeling incredibly
refreshed and energized I've been
sleeping on an eight- Sleep mattress
cover for almost 3 years now and it has
dramatically improved the quality of my
sleep so much so that when I travel and
I'm at a hotel or an Airbnb and I don't
have access to my eight sleep I very
much look forward to getting home
because my sleep is always better when I
sleep on my eights Sleep mattress cover
if you'd like to try eights sleep you
can go to 8sleep.com
/ huberman to get $150 off their pod
three mattress cover eight sleep
currently ships in the USA Canada UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's 8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by levels levels is a program that
lets you see how different foods affect
your health by giving you real-time
feedback on your diet using a continuous
glucose monitor one of the most
important factors in your immediate and
long-term health is your blood sugar or
blood glucose regulation with levels you
can see how different foods and food
combinations exercise and sleep patterns
impact your blood glucose levels it's
very easy to use you just put the
monitor on the back of your arm and then
you take your phone and you scan it over
that monitor now and again and it
downloads the data about your blood
sugar levels in the preceding hours
using levels has allowed me to learn a
tremendous amount about what works best
for me in terms of nutrition exercise
work schedules and sleep so if you're
interested in learning more about levels
and trying a continuous glucose monitor
you can go to levels. l/ huberman levels
has launched a new CGM sensor that is
smaller and has even better tracking
than the previous version right now
they're also offering an additional two-
free months of membership again that's
levels. linkhub to try the new sensor
and two free months of membership
today's episode is also brought To Us by
Aeropress Aeropress is similar to a
French press for making coffee but is in
fact a much better way to make coffee I
first learned about Aeropress well over
10 years a ago and I've been using one
ever since Aeropress was developed by
Allan Adler who was an engineer at
Stanford and I knew of Allen because he
had also built the so-called aobi
frisbee which I believe at one time
perhaps still now held the Guinness Book
of World Records for furthest Throne
object and I used to see Allan believe
it or not at parks around paloalto
testing out different aobi frisbee so he
was sort of famous in our community for
developing these different Feats of
engineering that turn turned into
commercial products now I love coffee
I'm somebody that drinks coffee nearly
every day usually about 90 to 120
minutes after I wake up in the morning
although not always sometimes if I'm
going to exercise I'll drink coffee
first thing in the morning but I love
love love coffee and what I've
personally found is that by using the
arero Press I can make the best possible
tasting cup of coffee I don't know what
exactly it is in the arero press that
allows the same beans to be prepared
into a cup of coffee that tastes that
much better as compared to any other
form of Brewing that coffee even the
traditional French press the Aero press
is extremely easy to use and it's
extremely compact in fact I take it with
me whenever I travel and I use it on the
road in hotels even on planes I'll just
ask for some hot water and I'll Brew my
coffee or tea right there on the plane
if you'd like to try Aeropress you can
go to Aero press.com huberman that's a r
o p
rs.com huberman to get 20% off any
Aeropress coffee maker Aeropress ships
anywhere in the USA Canada and over 60
other countries around the world again
that's Aero press.com huberman to get
20% off and now for my discussion with
Dr Robert lustig Dr Robert lustig
welcome pleasure truly uh just being
here being invited uh high honor really
appreciate it and it's not doctor it's
just Rob okay Rob I've been looking
forward to this conversation for a long
time I've seen your your now famous can
we also say Infamous but famous YouTube
video about sugar we'll put a link to it
in the show note captions it's been
viewed many many millions of times yeah
and I still can't figure out why that is
you know I didn't think my mother would
watch it and she didn't but 24 and a
half million people did well I think
people are very interested in what to
eat what not to eat and we'll start off
simply talking about what most everyone
believes and understands
which is that a calorie is a form of
heat
energy that's given off during the
processing of some food bit or something
if that's mysterious to people just
understand that a calorie is a unit of
energy and I was taught and still many
many people worldwide believe that a
calorie is a calorie meaning if I
consume more calories in whatever form
then I metabolize by thinking feeling
moving exercising Etc then I will gain
weight and if I consume fewer calories
than I burn I will lose weight and we
could talk a lot about where that weight
loss comes from does it come from
adapost body fat stores or from muscle
or from protein or muscle of course is
protein Etc but let's start off with is
a calorie truly a calorie when it comes
to the processing of different types of
calories everyone thinks that obesity is
about energy
balance that is calories in calories out
therefore two behaviors gluttony and
sloth therefore if you're fat it's your
fault
therefore diet and exercise therefore
any calorie can be part of a balanced
diet therefore don't pick on our
calories go pick on somebody else's
calories this is actually what the food
industry uses to assuage their
culpability for the change in the food
supply and the rise in obesity and
chronic disease like diabetes now it is
true that a calorie is that unit of
energy that raises one gram of water one
degree Centigrade and so therefore a
calorie burned is a calorie burned I
don't argue that that's true that's you
know the first law
thermodynamics but that doesn't mean a
calorie eaten is a calorie eaten that's
not the same and that's where people get
it wrong so let me give you some
examples of how that calorie eaten is
not a calorie
eating you like almonds I do me too
almonds are great okay you eat 160
calories in
almonds how many of those do you
absorb
130 you eat 160 you absorb 130 where'
the other 30 go in the processing of
that food energy
no turn out the fiber in those almonds
both soluble and insoluble fiber and by
the way fiber is sort of the key to the
kingdom in this
story forms a gel on the inside of your
intestine the insoluble fiber the
cellulose forms a fishnet if F A lattice
work on the inside of your dadum the
soluble fiber which are globular plug
the holes in that fish net together they
form a secondary barrier you can
actually see it on electron microscopy a
whitish gel and that prevents absorption
of those 30 calories so yes 130 get
absorbed but many of them don't they end
up going further down the intestine to
the next part called the junam and
that's where the microbiome is now now
everyone knows about the microbiome
nowadays you know it's all the bacteria
you know we always say when women are
pregnant you're eating for two well
we're always eating for 100
trillion now they have to eat well what
do they eat they eat what you eat the
question is how much did you get versus
how much did they get well if you ate
almonds they're getting those 30
calories so even though you count the
calories at your
lips that doesn't matter what really
matters is counting the Cal calories at
your intestinal brush
border okay and they're not the same so
if you feed your gut that's a good thing
because then your gut will take those
calories and turn it into things like
short chain fatty acids which end up
being protective against chronic
metabolic disease acetate propionate
butyrate valorate those are actually
good they're anti-inflammatory
anti-alzheimer's because you fed your
microbiome so even though you ate 160
you absorbed 130 so a calorie eaten is
not a calorie eaten because if you ate
it with fiber it wasn't for you it was
for your bacteria but that's not the way
you count them up so that's problem
number one problem number two amino
acids so we all eat
protein let's say you eat too much
protein you yeah you know the Porter
House steak all right now if you're a
bodybuilder
those amino acids might go to muscle and
you might increase your muscle mass
because you're a bodybuilder because
you're putting uh excess uh force on
those muscles and you're growing those
muscles okay but let's say you're not a
bodybuilder let's say you're a mere
moral like me or let's say you're a kid
going through puberty who's synthesizing
a lot of muscle not because they're
lifting weights because they're because
testosterone's making it happen yeah
absolutely but let's say you're not
let's say you know you're just you know
just slump off the the street like uh
you know joeo okay and you eat that
Porter
House you've taken on all these amino
acids there's no place to store it other
than muscle so your liver takes the
excess and deamidates that amino acid
takes the amino group off to turn it
from a amino acid into an organic acid
and then that organic acid can then
enter the kreb cycle the tricarboxylic
acid cycle what goes on in the
mitochondria in order to generate ATP
the chemical energy that your body needs
in order to power itself okay now that's
a good thing it takes double the amount
of energy to prepare that amino acid for
burning as it does to uh prepare a
carbohydrate for burning or fat for
because when I asked about when you
asked about almonds why the the 160
versus 130 I thought it was the
processing it turned out it was fiber
you're saying for protein let let's make
it realistic for a a really nice big
porterhouse steak which I love by the
way let's say let's say 800 calories
yeah well it turns out how much of that
is is uh so that's what goes in your
mouth right my mouth right how much of
it is actually um eaten in uh to stay
with the your calorie eaten is not a
calorie eaten in the processing of that
what percentages actually goes into your
total caloric intake right so about 10%
of everything you eat goes to just
maintaining body temperature it's called
the thermic effect of food but when
you're eating protein you actually
generate more Heat and the reason is
because it takes to ATP to phosphorate
that organic acid as opposed to one ATP
to uh phosphorate that carbohydrate for
uh consumption so you actually have a
net loss of energy because it was a an
amino acid versus a monosaccharide a
sugar now you you brought up fat fat
doesn't need to be phosphorated so it
actually doesn't have any um thermic
effective food at that point so depends
on what it is as to whether or not you
have loss okay so but in this um let's
make it actually realistic a 1600
calorie uh Porter House with a nice slab
of of uh of fed butter on there I do
this every once in a while not not often
with some cream spinach and maybe some
mushrooms along the side honestly I when
I'm eating a porter house I don't want
to adulterate The Taste okay with
anything else except maybe some some
butter maybe a salad okay afterwards but
but let's say 1 1600 calories of of it's
got some fat in there for sure uh let's
say um uh a thousand of those calories
is protein mhm the other 600 are
fat something like that like that
depending on how marbled it is okay so
based on what you just said about the
thermic effect of food and protein in
particular yeah of that thousand
calories how much actually is can we
count I'm not a calorie counter but does
one include as calories truly ingested
well if you ingested 1600 well that's
what went in the mouth but but but what
is is going to go against your your uh
burn deficit right so I would have to
actually do the math to figure that out
but as a guess yeah back of the envelope
back of the envelope calculation you're
going to lose about 25% of that wow so
we're talking 750 calories yeah you know
so and to translate this a bit so what
we're saying here is if you're somebody
who is trying to lose weight or maintain
weight or perhaps even gain weight you
eat a 1600 calorie Porter House with a
slab of butter on it 600 of those
calories we're saying in this instance
is fat with the remaining thousand
calories that's that all went in your
mouth so you count it at your mouth
right but 700 but then when you compare
it against your energy burn for that day
to maintain temperature brain activity
physical activity really it's only 750
calories that's right that's a huge
difference exactly and another reason
why a calorie is not a calorie now let's
take the third let's take fats so over
here we have omega-3s heart healthy
anti-inflammatory anti-alzheimer's save
your life and over here we have trans
fats the devil incarnate consumable
poison because you can't break the trans
double bond you don't have the
desaturates to break that trans double
bond so it basically accumulates lines
your arteries lines your liver causes
chronic metabolic disease causes insulin
resistance
Omega-3s don't even get broken down for
energy because they're so important they
stay intact because your brain needs
them your heart needs
them whereas trans fats can't be broken
down because of that trans double bond
one save your life other one kill you
they're both nine calories per gram if
you explode them in a bomb calorimeter
because a calorie burned is a calorie
burned but a calorie eaten is not a
calorie eaten because one will save your
life one will kill
you and finally the Big Kahuna the one
that blows everything else out of the
water from ose and glucose all right now
glucose is the energy of life so here
we're talking carbohydrates I think most
of our audience will be familiar with
the so-call macronutrients so we talked
about fat in this case almonds there's
some Fiber in there probably a little
bit of carbohydrate a little bit little
bit talked about the Porter House with
butter right making me hungry already
that's protein and fat M very little of
any carbohydrate it should be zero
essentially maybe one zero zero y
um and then now we're talking about
carbohydrates and we're going to
subdivide that into glucose and fructose
right galactose basically becomes
glucose in the liver so we we can
dispense with that unless you have a
disease called galactosemia which is
about one in 20,000 um and causes
neonatal menitis and you know it's a
disease as a pediatric endocrinologist I
would take care of but we can dispense
with that for the moment all right so
glucose fructose glucose is the energy
of life every cell on the planet Burns
glucose for energy glucose is so damn
important that if you don't consume it
your body makes it so it will take an
amino acid and turn it into glucose
that's gluconeogenesis glucogenesis
that's right it will take a fatty acid
and turn it into glucose and
specifically the glycerol portion of the
triglyceride will turn into
glucose
so the
Inuit they didn't have any place to grow
carbohydrate they had ice they had whale
blubber they still have serum glucose
level and the reason is because you had
to you have to have a serum glucose
level in order to power your brain in
order to power your heart yes you you
can use ketones of course you can but
you know only if you're in a ketogenic
state will you use exclusively ketones
and you also need glucose for structural
changes in specific proteins and
particularly hormones so glucose
molecules will stud TSH LH FSH different
pituitary hormones in order to increase
their potency it's one of the reasons
why aging leads to defective
hormonogenesis for instance hypogonadism
hypothyroidism is the loss of
glycosilation on individual um uh uh
peptide hormones because of uh the
inability to add glucose because of
insulin just it's an aging phenomenon
okay we'll come back to this cuz I think
that's really important yeah the idea
that ingestion of
carbohydrates and the as you called it
the studing of carbohydrate molecules on
hormones can augment the function of
those hormones and with aging that's a
less efficient process it's a less
efficient process but it's not because
of consumption it's right people are
still I I see the the uh plenty of folks
who are uh 65 and older eating plenty of
carbohydrates you're saying a lot of
them have deficient thyroid testosterone
estrogen right um prolactin Etc because
of the Wes those carbohydrates are not
studing the uh the hormones exactly so
they're all of those are glycoprotein
hormones let's tea that up for later
because I think that's an interesting
Avenue to go down okay and there's a and
there's a disease in children in in
babies called congenital disorders of
glycosilation where you can't put uh uh
glucose Mo uh molecules on specific
proteins and it causes severe mental
retardation all sorts of metabolic havoc
and a lot of those babies die for that
matter so that's an important thing all
right but that's how important glucose
is fructose on the other hand this sweet
molecule the molecule we seek the reason
why the food industry studs every food
in the grocery store you know 73% of all
items in the American Grocery Store have
added sugar on purpose for the food
industry's purpose is not for yours
because fructose is addictive activates
the nucleus accumbens the reward center
of the brain in the same way that
cocaine heroin nicotine alcohol do and
drives dopamine receptors down just like
nicotine you know alcohol you know
cocaine heroin
do that molecule
fructose is number one uh completely
vestigial to all vertebrate life there
is no biochemical reaction in any
vertebrate that requires dietary
fructose that's number one number two
okay sorry I'm going to juster so you're
saying that even though we can process
fructose we have a limited capacity to
process it in the same way we have a
limited capacity to metabolize
alcohol now if you have one drink a day
you you're okay if you have two drinks a
day depends on how big you are you know
you and I can probably I would argue two
drinks a week is the maximum but but
let's not go there the um but but in
terms of you're saying when you
say fructose processing a fructose is
vestigal what you're saying is that we
don't need to do it it's like the
appendix it's an organ for which it has
no function exactly and fructose has no
function in the human body period you
don't need it you don't need it don't
need it but our diet is replete with it
in fact our fructose consumption has
gone up 25 fold since the beginning of
the last century I have to ask this now
I love fruit I eat berries Galore
especially since the price of berries
seems to have come down it used to be
that you only get them certain times of
year I'm what you call a drive by
blueberry eater so I'll just walk past
and just take a fist full you can't put
them in front of me without me eating
them this is even difficult for me when
other people I don't know are eating
them so um I lots of blueberries
strawberries blackberries if they're in
season I love them no problem loaded
with fructose no plenty of fiber low
fructose low fructose and berries
berries are the lowest fructose of all
the so worried about asking you this
today okay um and fruit is okay because
of the fiber so the molecule the
fructose molecule is the same whether
it's in a berry or in a banana or for
that matter in in a Coca-Cola the
fructose molecule is the same molecule
the difference is that in the berry it
comes with a whole lot of fiber and the
banana comes with a whole lot less fiber
and in the Coca-Cola it doesn't come
with any fiber and the fiber is what
mitigates the
absorption so when you consume the
fructose with fiber so your blueberries
you're feeding your
microbiome that fructose wasn't for you
got it such a relief and um
I I must say recently I had a whole body
MRI as a preemptive thing uh someone
that it was it was great I got to watch
a Netflix in there and um I never had a
whole body MRI I learned a few things
that were useful to me I've got a clean
bill of health so that's great one of
the pie of feedback I got is um that my
gut was filled with this very high
contrast um stuff right and they asked
you know do you consume a lot of
blueberries and I said indeed I do why
and they said um because that high
contrast offf it shows up white on the
scan is um high concentrations of
magnesium MH um that we see in people
that ingest large amounts of blueberries
which is pretty rare and yours are
comparable to a bear in blueberry season
wow um and basically my entire gut was
filled with with blueberries I suppose I
need to cut back a little bit but now I
know that fruit is okay especially if
the fruit has a lot of fiber yeah but
fructose itself especially if it's not
partnered with fiber yeah is first of
all not required for survival at all but
you're telling me is uh problematic yeah
and let me tell you why it's problematic
we haven't gotten to that yet we're just
talking about whether it's vestigal
versus needed now let's talk about what
fructose
does turns out fructose inhibits three
count them three separate enzymes
necessary for normal mitochondrial
function now your mitochondrial make ATP
your mitochondria have to work at Peak
efficiency that's what metabolic health
is is mitochondri are working at Peak
efficiency well there are three enzymes
that are inhibited by fructose number
one amp kinas all right now amp kinas is
the fuel gauge on the liver cell it's
the thing that tells the liver to make
more mitochondria fresher mitochondria
because if your amp levels are high that
means means you've def phosphorated a
bunch of atps and you have to regenerate
them so you need some more mitochondria
so it's a negative feedback pathway well
you need that amp kinas to generate that
mitochondrial biogenesis signal except
that fructose a metabolite of fructose
called methylglyoxal
MGO sits in the active site of the gamma
subunit of that amp kinas and actually
binds to arginines in that active site
rendering that uh uh enzyme now dead
it's an irreversible inhibition because
of the Cove valent bonding of that
methylglyoxal that alahh to the Arginine
and now that enzyme is dead Okay so it
basically acts like a key that doesn't
turn the lock but prevents the the key
that you want in that lock from entering
the the lock it's like it's like gluing
a lock shut yeah got it all right so
that's one of the enzymes that's one
okay second one aad L asil COA
dehydrogenase longchain so this is
necessary to cleave two carbon fragments
of fatty acids to prepare them for uh uh
metabolism so it inhibits that one and
then finally it inhibits carnitine pidal
transferase one now cpt1 now that's the
enzyme that regenerates carnitine
carnitine is the shuttle mechanism by
which you get the uh fatty acids from
the outer mitochondrial membrane
through to the inner mitochondrial
membrane so that they can be beta
oxidized for energy so if you don't have
that c uh
cpt1 you're basically carnitin lless and
therefore you can't generate um beta
oxidation you said fructose inhibits all
three of these enzymatic Pathways y as a
biologist I have to ask you know how
potently does it inhibit them I mean
because there's there are drugs that
block receptors and then there are drugs
that block receptors with in
unbelievable Affinity so you know I mean
mechanistically in a dish meaning in
vitro you can see all sorts of things
but how how significant is this for like
for obesity for mitochondrial function
in Vivo in us all right so look you know
the the dose determines the poison right
paracelsus
1537 um there are toxins that are parts
per billion and will kill you like sarin
rysen Cyanide by the way I is a good
analogy because it's working on
mitochondria it's basically causing
mitochondria to be completely defective
all right then there are um intermediate
toxins like Arsenic and carbon
tetrachloride parts per million and they
take a little longer to work they're not
going to kill you on the spot that's why
I can eat an apple seed that has a
little bit of arsenic in it but I'm not
going to die right and then finally
there and by the tobacco smoke goes in
there and then finally you have um uh
weak toxins all right and you know where
it's not one exposure that will kill you
it's you know 10,000 exposures that'll
kill you like alcohol or toxic people
yeah or toxic
well toxic couldn't resist sorry
sometimes it don't mildly toxic people
anyway the point is that fructose is in
that last category so it's not what you
do one day that kills you it's what you
do every day that kills you and if you
basically eat Ultra processed food high
in sugar for 10 years in a row it's
going to show up in terms of your
comorbidities and ultimately yeah it
will kill you and we have the data to
show you know how many years you will
lose so right now in America we pay an
8year longevity tax if you look at Japan
who uh they have a mean age of death of
88 we have a mean age of 80 okay we're
paying an eight-year longevity tax just
by living here and we're talking about
the healthy people now if you have
metabolic syndrome it's a 15-year
longevity tax and uh sorry if you
obesity it's a 15year longevity taxt and
if you have metabolic syndrome it's a
20-year longevity
taxt that is primarily not completely
but primarily sugar it's also you know
omega-6 it's also trans fats you know
left over because now they're gone but
you know people are still suffering the
ravages of the trans fats you know from
the previous generation are they gone I
mean I do remember as a kid when we had
margarine in our refrigerator this is
actually a big debate in my home one
parent I won't identify which um was Pro
margarine the other was Pro butter anti-
margarine right um the marriage didn't
last but there were other reasons that's
probably why I went butter um butter is
fine in fact time declared you know
front cover Butter's back you know um
margarine was the bad guy without
question U and we know now but you know
back when we thought it was a calorie
was a calorie we thought oh margarine
you know it's the same you know nine
calories per gram and we said it lowers
your
triglycerides bad idea it was because
what it did was it lined your liver
because you couldn't break that trans
double
bond and um you know so they're they're
now gone from our uh food supply they're
illegal they're illegal they're banned
but you can make trans fats in your own
kitchen by taking olive oil and heating
it to beyond the smoking point so
they're not completely gone they're just
gone from ultr processed food so now
sugar is the big problem because of
these three enzymes that you are
inhibiting the point is we were we
started this with a calorie is a calorie
well if you are inhibiting mitochondrial
function then a calorie is not a calorie
is it you're reducing the um intensity
of the Furnace yeah exactly so this
whole calories of calorie just makes no
sense and it hasn't worked at any level
and there is no study that actually
shows that cutting calories makes a
difference and I can show you you know
voluminous data that shows that virtu Al
every weight loss study that caus that
led to you know caloric restriction
basically didn't work not for any length
of time just to round out our earlier
discussion because I find it fascinating
and I know other people will as well
talked about that 160 calories that's
actually 130 at the business end of
things uh of almonds we talked about the
Porter House steak with butter and the
25% reduction in what's actually quote
unquote eaten and I'll get back to this
because this quote unquote is I think
the problem is there's there's a lack of
useful language to dissociate this stuff
you know even just calling fat fat
people think it it's going to make you
gain body fat totally if we called it
adapost tissue and lipids we would have
avoided this confusion so I I don't want
to get there just yet but I I want to
make sure with the food industry does
this on purpose oh absolutely so they
tell you a sugar is a sugar which is not
true they tell you a calor is a calorie
which is not true and they tell you a
fat is a fat which is not true okay this
is very specifically so when you're
talking about sugar you're talking about
dietary sugar are you talking about
blood sugar because blood sugar is blood
glucose or dietary cholesterol or
circulating cholesterol or you
absolutely okay so we we've done this um
you know uh to ourselves but the food
industry has really promulgated it
because we farmed out nutrition policy
and information to the food in so they
actually use this for their purposes
it's one of the problems in this
field as we all know quality nutrition
influences of course our physical health
but also our mental health and our
cognitive functioning our memory our
ability to learn new things and to focus
and we know that one of the most
important features of highquality
nutrition is making sure that we get
enough vitamins and minerals from
highquality unprocessed or minimally
processed sources as well as enough
probiotics and prebiotics and fiber to
support basically basally all the
cellular functions in our body including
the gut microbiome now I like most
everybody try to get optimal nutrition
from Whole Foods ideally mostly from
minimally processed or non-processed
Foods however one of the challenges that
I and so many other people face is
getting enough servings of high quality
fruits and vegetables per day as well as
fiber and probiotics that often
accompany those fruits and vegetables
that's why way back in 2012 long before
I ever had a podcast I started drinking
ag1 and so I'm Ed the ag1 is sponsoring
the hubman Lab podcast the reason I
started taking ag1 and the reason I
still drink ag1 once or twice a day is
that it provides all of my foundational
nutritional needs that is it provides
insurance that I get the proper amounts
of those vitamins minerals probiotics
and fiber to ensure optimal mental
health physical health and performance
if you'd like to try ag1 you can go to
drink a1.com huberman to claim a special
offer they're giving away five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink a1.com
huberman to claim that special offer for
the third category of macronutrients
carbohydrates you differentiated um
glucose and fructose MH if I ingest um
let's say a half a bagel um since we
were talking about New York your city of
origin they have great Bagels on the
west coast yeah know not the same it's
it's pretty pitiful same with the pizza
dough it's like they claim it's the the
the water whatever it is it's different
back there and it's better indeed half a
bagel let's say 250 calories mostly
carbohydrate mhm this is an an unlined
un no cream cheese no shmear as they
call back there no no cream cheese no
butter none that just half a bagel 250
calories so that's what I ate you're
saying that a calorie eaten is not a
calorie eaten how much of that
carbohydrate given that it's probably
most let's assume it's mostly glucose
let's do it this way yeah it is it's
polymerized glucose okay glucose how
much of that is actually utilized or
burned versus um you know the original
250 so if you look at what happens to
energy in the body
65% of that which is ingested goes to
resting energy expenditure just to power
the body 10% goes to the thermic effect
of food and then 25% goes to activity
that's the breakdown of where the uh
energy goes and that's calories from fat
protein and carbohydrates yeah from
everything together and you know glucose
is a perfectly good example of how that
works the point is though that when you
ingest glucose you're getting a big
glucose Excursion in your bloodstream so
you're getting a big glucose Spike and
that glucose Spike has to come down well
what makes it come down the hormone
insulin insulin is the bad guy in the
story
the higher your glucose goes the more
your pancreas will release insulin in
order to bring that glucose down Well
turns out that glucose rise was not
benign that glucose rise led to
endothelial dysfunction transient but
nonetheless endothelial dysfunction
could you just um remind people what
endothelial cells are the inside of your
arteries okay and it will change blood
pressure we've got plenty of data to
demonstrate how it changes blood
pressure and over time that will cause
coronary artery disease that will cause
kidney disease Etc but it's the insulin
response that is really the bad guy now
people think insulin is good because it
lowers blood glucose after all diabetics
take insulin you know to lower their
blood
glucose okay let's take a diabetic
patient with diabetes blood sugar's 300
that's bad we give them a shot of
insulin in the arm blood sugar goes down
down to 100 blood sugar went from 300 to
100 okay where did the 200 points of
blood glucose
go I'm assuming that the insulin was
sequestered it to where I'm assuming to
the liver to the fat interesting for
storage that's insulin's job insulin
takes whatever you're not burning and
puts it into fat for storage insulin is
not the diabetes hormone insulin is the
energy stor hormone how quickly does it
do that because because if I'm you know
having a a very busy day mhm or that a
diabetic person is having a very busy
day and they're moving around a lot then
you got insulin bound glucose in the
bloodstream uh for how long no no
insulin doesn't bind glucose insulin
binds to its receptor sure sorry Sor and
allows for glucose Transporters to work
so so but for some period of time while
that person is active There's an
opportunity to utilize that glucose yeah
right yeah um so how quickly is insulin
managing that glucose uh we know that
the spike comes down quickly but the
glucose is not available for energy
utilization after what it's or it's it's
sequestered to the the adapost to the
fat tissue at within an hour is that
about so about 90 minutes yeah but I
mean if if you're if you're active if
you eat uh you know a muffin and you're
active Okay your muscles are going to
take up that glucose IR perspective of
insulin in fact muscles are insulin
independent they have glucose
Transporters but they are insulin
independent because if they weren't then
every patient in diabetic keto acidosis
would be paralyzed okay so glucose will
end up in muscles irrespective of energy
status and uh insulin status and in
muscles it's used as immediate Fuel and
glycogen both okay met Fuel and glycogen
storage okay in the muscle
absolutely all right now if you're
active then you will clear glucose into
muscle Therefore your blood glucose
won't rise as much because it went into
muscle and therefore your pancreas will
put out less insulin because it doesn't
have to clear as much from the
bloodstream and that's okay that's good
right but let's say you didn't exercise
so you've got a big glucose Excursion
now you have a big insulin response and
that insulin is going to take the excess
that's in your blood it has to clear it
and it will go to fat for storage that
insulin rise turns out to be
particularly egregious in terms of
metabolic disease and I can prove it
there is a mouse my favorite Mouse I
love this mouse this mouse turns
medicine on its head and teaches every
doctor why they have to go back to
medical school and learn it
right this mouse is called the padco
mouse p o d i r KO is it discovered by
padco no no it was uh discovered in Ron
K it was manufactured in Ron cons lab so
this is a tissue specific insulin
receptor knockout Mouse Okay IR KO
insulin LAX insulin receptor in specific
the kidney in the kidney interco
glomular poicy insulin receptor knockout
we haven't talked too much about
transgenic models and knockins and
Knockouts so uh just in 10 seconds or Le
basically these are mice that are
genetically engineered to lack the
receptor for insulin specifically in the
glul poite the kidney in the in the
kidney and everywhere else in this mouse
insulin does its thing normally exactly
great so these animals are ug glycemic
normal blood glucose levels these
animals are normally glucose tolerant
they you know go up they go down just
like every other
Mouse these mice are not fat these mice
are not thin these mice are
mice except they have the worst diabetic
nephropathy on the planet so their ner
oh their kidney is degenerative their
kidneys is degenerate to nothing yikes
now they have normal blood glucose
levels they have normal glucose
tolerance they have normal insulin
tolerance whole body but they're kidneys
are
dying how come can't be the
glucose it's the
insulin because insulin is the bad guy
insulin's actually making the kidney
disease and so these animals that are
insulin resistant they have diabetic
nephropathy without
diabetes so the insulin is having a
negative clearly negative effect on the
kidneys without binding to the receptor
exactly so circulating insulin can do
stuff without binding to its receptor
well it's no it binds to its receptor in
different parts of the body other parts
of the body party it can't because it's
a knockout because it's knockout right
the point is insulin does stuff by
itself and it turns out insulin drives
growth now every cell in your
body wants to burn at one time in its
life and wants to grow at another time
in life every cell has those two
Pathways burning growth burning growth
what determines whether a
cell should be burning or whether a cell
should be growing I don't know what
makes it um burning but presumably it's
in the has something to do with
mitochondria it has everything to do
with mitochondria right so every cell
needs to burn and needs to grow at a
different time in its life here's a way
to think about it we all start out as a
zygote a single
cell we end up an
adult now that single cell had to become
two
cells those two cells had to become four
cells those four cells had to become
eight cells and on and on and on and on
so every cycle there's a
doubling how many doublings to get from
a zygote to an adult what's an
exponential growth so yeah I don't I
don't know it off the top of my head
41 41 41 two to the 41 doublings giv you
an organism 10 trillion cells we're 10
trillion cells we're 10 trillion cells
did we know that yeah okay two to the 41
okay okay now of those 41 doublings some
of them had to occur in
utero some of them had to occur
postnatally so I need two numbers that
add up to 41 how many in utero how many
postnatally well way
more you start off with a lot more than
you end up with but then you have cells
that turn over throughout the lifespan
so this is a tough one okay because skin
cells turnover I I with neurons it's
it's pretty straightforward because
you're going to somewhere between three
and 10 right well you're and you're born
with somewhere between 3 and 10x of what
you end up with depending on the brain
structure so but for whole body I don't
know how you'd come up with that number
36 and
five okay 36 doublings
prenatally five doublings postnatally
and I can prove that to you too typical
baby weighs s pounds first doubling 14
pounds second doubling 208 lb next
doubling 56 lb next doubling 112 lb next
doubling 224 lb that's hopefully it
stops OB division hopefully it stops
there not not all people 212 lbs are
obese um but some people who are of
certain Heights or below are 212 aerobes
okay point is the cell has to know when
to grow and when to burn it turns out
that the signal for that is
oxygen because oxygen is necessary for
mitochondria to be able to burn in the
absence of oxygen the cell only knows
how to grow this is actually why OT
warberg won the Nobel Prize in 19 1931
for the warberg effect he asked the
question how come cancer cells don't
need oxygen to grow and the answer is
because no cell needs oxygen to grow in
fact oxygen is the thing that prevents
growth famous article from the New
England Journal of Medicine 1951 Mount
Everest in utero because every
fetus is oxygen
deprived so normal
partial pressure of oxygen 100 millim of
mercury out here right if if I checked
your blood it'd be about 100 right I
hope so how about a tumor cell um
guessing tumor cell is
probably is it double about 44 wait you
just told me partial pressure of of
oxygen in a tumor cell it's about 44
well you just told me that well tumor
cells which grow like wild right they
grow like wild because they don't have
oxygen
but they but there's some of the so
here's what's peculiar about it um tumor
cells are some of the most vascularized
cells or tumors are are heavily
vascularized I mean I mean one way to
one way to try and kill one is to to
devascularize the tumor yes and you know
Ang Genesis inhibition Etc you it's a
big deal you know Judah folman and all
that from Harvard you know so the excess
blood to a tumor is the attempt to bring
in oxygen that it's not getting that's
right as opposed to deliv in lots of
oxygen and that's why it's growing
that's right okay but a fetus what's the
partial pressure in the placenta I don't
know 6 to
31 so it's actually like a mile above
Mount Everest that's how much oxygen the
fetus gets and it's that for that reason
that you've got 36 doublings and then as
soon as you're out you know you cut the
cord and you start breathing and now
your partial pressure is at 100 that's
when growth slows down
has there been any effort to treat
tumors by oxygenating tumors yes and
what does that look like it's hyperbaric
oxygen therapy it's a thing oh yeah yeah
yeah we we'll probably do an episode on
hyperbaric chambers it's the the the
reason we haven't yet is it's pretty
niche in but there are people who own
these things who sit in these things um
okay so we got here by way of by way of
car by The Bagel right um so I just want
to orient us um that you just that 250
calories of the The Bagel we talked
about glucose excursions but it's that
insulin rise that's driving the atopos
it's also driving the
growth okay in the absence of oxygen
because if you have oxygen then you
don't need that much
insulin okay
so because you're going to burn instead
of store got
it in terms of the the uh the raw
metabolism
of carbohydrate though that glucose if I
eat 250 calories of glucose how much of
that did I quote unquote actually eat
how much is is used how much is used
yeah let's assume that I'm I'm at my
desk working or I'm walking around a
little bit I'm not I'm not exercising
hard in the in the subsequent hour so
used for what is the question I'm
getting back to the calorie is is a
calorie a calorie clearly the answer is
no based on the processing of different
types of calories we established it for
fat the almonds we establish it for
protein
the Porter House with butter and now
we're we're trying to establish that for
the 250 calories of of bagel which is
glucose right so the glucose has to be
phosphorated so you're going to lose uh
an ATP in the process so you're going to
go ATP goes to ADP and then that ADP
will go to am a denzine monophosphate
which will then go to im an ocol
monophosphate which will then go to uric
acid okay and that uric acid will be
then released from the cell circulate in
the bloodstream and hopefully go out in
the kidney in the process that uric acid
can inhibit mitochondrial function and
it can also inhibit endothelial nitric
oxide synthese which is the enzyme in
your vasculature that is your endogenous
blood pressure lowerer right by
expanding blood vessels and capillaries
exactly right this is the mechanistic uh
foundation of the drugs that were
originally used for uh improving
prostate function but are used to treat
erectile dysfunction which are the the
PD Inhibitors which allow nitric oxide
to be uh around longer and more of it
right people use it for other purposes
too um now no one will forget if I queue
it up with that that example well we we
uh you know in the neonatal Intensive
Care Unit it closes patent ductus
arteriosis which is a big deal in uh in
the neonatal uh uh World okay I I want
to ask you about that but but um so I
heard two things one is that um gluc ose
and the insulin that goes with it
increases uric acid MH uric acid while
it has certain important functions in
health too much of it you said Can
inhibit nitric oxide yeah can inhibit
nitric oxide so that means that the
blood vessels and capillaries are going
to stay more constricted so blood
pressure is going to be higher than it
would be normally that's right and then
uric acid is also inhibiting
mitochondrial function that's right okay
um but eating half a bagel isn't
necessarily a terrible thing if it's
within your caloric require requirements
it and it it all depends on how much uh
you clear and how high your insulin goes
now let's compare that 250 calories of
glucose to 250 calories of fructose
right uh let's let's come up with a food
example 250 calories of fructose would
be trivial to uh consume in the form of
high fructose corn syrup right well so
remember that high fructose corn syrup
is half glucose half fructose 125 125 so
let's not use that well so let's assume
um so we can talk about a soda for uh to
get that that uh 250 calories easily um
especially if it's not a can or a
European siiz bottle or can 8 o 8 oz can
of soda okay so 8 oce can of soda um and
maybe let's include a food item let's
talk like a store-bought packaged cookie
couple Oreos two Oreos okay probably get
you to that 250 or maybe four Oreos
maybe three Oreos yeah okay um Oreo
lovers everywhere celebrate
three 250 calories of
fructose what's the effect on uric acid
what's the effect on caloric burn what's
the effect on anything for that matter
that uh we should be aware of all right
so first of all the Oreo has plenty of
fructose in it so keep that in mind okay
the um if let's say you consumed uh 250
calories in a bagel because that's
pretty much polymerized glucose versus
say the soda so the bagel versus the
soda that's what you're equalent
calories equalent calories or the The
Bagel versus let's say two Oreos and a
little bit of um and yeah two Oreos okay
so number one there's only half the
glucose in the soda because the other
half is the fructose it's 125125 so your
glucose rise won't be as high your
glucose Excursion will be lower this is
actually one of the reasons why there's
this thing called glycemic index
glycemic index is a Canard it's garbage
it is complete and utter BS the glycemic
index absolute BS nothing nothing is
more um uh egregious in terms of uh
argument than then than the glycemic
index and this is one of the things that
dietitians promote and espouse and one
of the things that's got to go okay this
is an idea that must die okay we'll get
back to why the glycemic index has got
to die uh but so so the 250 calories and
actually can we can we make these equal
just for sake of of Simplicity can we
say 250 calories of glucose from The
Bagel versus 250 calories of fructose
how do we get 250 calories of pure
fructose we don't you can't okay you got
to bring the glucose with lab Lab
fructose you'd have to make it with the
Oreos which is half glucose half
fructose right I mean there is no
fructose alone in nature even crackers
some of the ones that are salty are also
sweet they have fructose in them
Abus yeah that's why it's impossible to
eat just one indeed um so what's
happening biochemically as a consequence
of the fructose component specifically
so the fructose will first of all go
into the intestine the intestine will
metabolize some of that fructose through
what is known as intestinal denova
lipogenesis about 10% of that fructose
will be turned into fat right in the
intestine and that's cuz fructose it
just wants to be fat yeah fructose wants
to be fat fructose is the lipogenic
substrate here we're not talking about
body fat we're talking about fat
molecules that can potentially be used
as energy that's right triglyceride
molecules okay so that so 10% of that
fructose will be turned into
triglyceride right in the intestine and
be released into the bloodstream and it
is the reason for a post prandial
triglyceride response postprandial is uh
and I'm including myself in this group
is nerd speak for after eating lunch
typically it's
lunch so that's actually one of the
drivers of cardiovascular pathology that
intestinal denova lipogenesis turning
that fructose into triglyceride right in
the intestine now there's a limit to how
fast and how much the intestine can do
that the rest of the fructose will be uh
absorbed into the portal vein but not
before some of that fructose will make
it further down and it will Nitro create
tight Junction proteins now okay portal
ve the kidney portal ve goes to the
liver portal vean goes from the visceral
from the intestine to the liver no K
doesn't feed the kidney no
kidney intestine to liver okay okay but
fructose nitrates tight Junction
proteins now let me explain that to your
audience your intestine is a
sewer definition of a sewer a pipe with
in it okay that's a sewer our
intestines are
sewers there's junk in the center and
the job of the intestine is to move the
junk through to the anus absorbing the
good stuff while you can the intestine
is made up of cells intestinal
epithelial cells that are bound together
and they're bound with proteins that
basically form a barrier those barriers
called tight Junction proteins things
like cloudin and things like that um
zulin is the main one okay there are
others but zulin is the one that goes is
defective in the celiac disease what
defines a tight Junction is it is like
completely impermeable or semi-permeable
completely impermeable okay unless its
function is inhibited turns out if you
alter the um phosphorilation status or
the nitrate status of that tight
Junction it will will become transiently
permeable okay and so fructose nitrates
TI Junction proteins causing them to be
transiently permeable allowing some of
the junk in your intestine to get
through into your bloodstream so this is
leaky gut this is leaky gut this is what
causes leaky gut fructose is a driver of
leaky gut got it that causes
inflammation at the level of the liver
which ultimately leads to systemic
inflammation one of the reasons why High
Sensi CRP sensitivity CRP is high in
patients who eat ultrapress food CRP is
C reactive protein which is a marker of
a essentially inflammatory immune
response exactly yeah you don't want it
too high and 93% of Americans today are
inflamed does that mean that 93% of
Americans have leaky guts yeah it does
because that's where it comes from so in
addition to limiting fructose intake
MH what are things that um support the
tight junctions of of the intestinal
pathway so there are three barriers in
your intestine to keep the junk where it
belongs in the center so that it can get
pooped out the you're behind all right
three separate barriers one is a
physical barrier called the muin layer
so it's a layer of mucus that actually
sits on top of the intestinal epithelial
cells now now that mucin is a
polysaccharide and the bacteria can use
that mucin layer for its own purposes it
will eat your mucin layer if you don't
feed your bacteria you must feed your
bacteria or your bacteria will feed on
you MH okay so you are in concert with
your microbiome if you deprive your
microbiome of the food that it needs it
will use you as its food and that's one
of the reasons why fire fiber is so
important so fiber to build up this muin
layer is one way to reinforce the the uh
the fence that that is the tight
junctions Etc ex um between your
intestine and the bloodstream exactly
this raises an interesting point about
fasting many people including myself do
a sort of pseudo intermittent fasting I
eat my first meal somewhere between 11:
and noon I'm not strict about this the
11 versus noon thing and probably eat my
last bite of food somewhere around 8:00
p.m. and occasionally it's outside that
window I've done this for a long time
it's feels best to me right but other
people use a shorter eating window one
thing that I learned from a colleague at
Yale who studies the gut microbiome that
was surprising to me is that when you do
when you eat in that way there's a long
stretch of time sometimes longer for
people that have a shorter eating window
longer fasting what know that is yeah
where you're actually eating up your own
intestinal lining so this idea that
fasting is so great for us on the one
hand might be true on the other hand
you're you're actually consuming
assuming components of your you're not
feeding your gut microbiome and you
deplete it but then here's where I was
positively surprised when you do eat
provided that you eat enough fiber and
in particular high quality fermented
foods low sugar fermented foods it seems
that the the lining of the gut and the
gut microbiome is replenished to a level
that is greater than if you had eaten
for longer periods of the 24-hour cycle
do I have that right we do you do have
it right and I don't know why that is
true but it does seem to be the case and
fermented foods B in part because
they've got already short chain fatty
acids in them um see the preferred food
of the microbiome well it's what the
microbiome actually turns fiber into so
it's probably helping your intestinal
epithelial cells in the same way what
the microbiome turning fiber into short
chain fatty acids helps so it's what we
call a postbiotic so you have Prebiotic
which is the food for the bacteria you
have the probiotic which is the the
bacteria itself and then you have the
postbiotic which is what the bacteria
make in order to heal you okay and so
short chain fatty acids are postbiotics
and there are a lot of people selling
short chain fatty acids you know drinks
and supplements and what have you
whether they work or not is another
story if I consume fructose in the uh
form of let's say a highly processed
food has minimal antioxidants but it's
got plenty of calories typically um Y
and it's disrupting the tight junctions
making my gut leaky right but I'm also
eating fiber y you know I'm having a you
know a meal that includes a salad I'm
having having some probiotics and then I
want like a couple rees's peanut butter
cups like in the dark chocolate ones in
particular I don't do this anymore but I
used to eat like that more often as as
time has gone on I've become I don't
like to call it stricter but more I I I
tend to like healthier foods over time
and I think you can get away with
different things at different stages of
Life although you work with young people
so we'll uh we'll get to very young
people so we'll get to this but how how
much damage am I doing by ingesting any
fructose in the form of a highly
processed food so I'll make it very
simple
Andrew I am for
dessert for dessert I am not for dessert
for breakfast lunch snacks and dinner
okay so if you want to have a couple of
ree's peanut butter cups as your dessert
in the same way as you might have a
conac for
dessert that's fine I have no problem
with that the question is are you going
to eat re's peanut butter cuffs for
breakfast no I don't eat breakfast but
no I got but I see your point the
National School breakfast program which
29% of school children today consume is
a bowl of fro loops and a glass of
orange juice that is 41 gam of sugar
American Heart associate says that the
upper limit for children should be 12
gram of added sugar per day that's 41
grams of added sugar and it's just
breakfast and that's fructose Rich
totally completely so the question is
which dessert are we talking about and
right and can we can we adjust that
morning meal um to a different reality
cuz I agree that there are plenty of
kids eating that or a muffin that might
be the equivalent um but what about the
parent who's has okay let's come up with
a healthier option that the kids still
likes like a I'm thinking back to my
childhood like a honeynut Cheerios or
something so not Froot Loops which is
kind of the extreme um take a look at
the side of the package no difference
and now let's say they go with um some
uh like waffles that are made so with a
with a pre-made U mix some milk some
butter um you know so mom or dad is
making waffles great it sounds healthier
but then if you do the breakdown or
we're still ending up at very high are
we basically eating dessert for
breakfast in Cas are we eating ego
waffles or we uh making waffles uh
denovo you know from scratch in your own
kitchen let's say big
difference okay because the Eggo waffles
you know replete with sugar on purpose
because the food industry knows when
they add it you buy more because it's
addictive okay and we actually have the
um uh uh demographic the mechanistic the
Imaging and also the economic data to
demonstrate that Sugar's addictive and
the food industry knows it so have you
ever heard of a phenomenon called price
elasticity okay price elasticity is an
economic term that is used to ask the
question if the price of a given good
goes up by
1% that should result in reduction in
purchase or consumption because price
influences
consumption how much does it influence
it so if it's if something's price
elastic when the price goes up
consumption goes down
equivalently a food that is price
elastic the most price elastic food is
eggs so when the price of eggs goes up
1% consumption of eggs goes down
68% meaning that eggs have a price
elasticity of.
32 got it got it now what's the most
pric in elastic
food the top three most price inelastic
foods are fast food Cal can1 I like a
good quiz fast food 081 um uh uh soft
drinks at 79 and juice at 77 meaning
people will pay not whatever but they'll
they're willing to pay more more more
readily willing to pay more because of
the sugar because it's addictive because
it's honic so many many years ago Andrew
you probably remember something called
Keynesian economics and Keynesian
economics was based on this concept of
the rational actor and the rational
actor can determine value which is
utility over
cost and if you're a rational actor you
should be able to say yeah I'll buy that
but I won't buy that right
okay in
1979 Daniel canaman and Amos
fski Nobel Prize winner Daniel canaman
describ the irrational
actor now the irrational actor cannot
determine value and the reason is
because he is risk averse so the cost is
always too great so the utility may be
the same but the cost goes up because
that's why they have you know aversive
Tendencies the irrational actor Jeffrey
Sachs has described the honic actor who
also cannot determine value because it
doesn't matter what it costs they need
their
fix and this is what's going on and the
food industry knows it and that's why
every food in the store has been
spiked I'd like to take a quick break to
acknowledge our sponsor element elements
is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't that means zero sugar and the
appropriate ratios of the electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium and that
correct ratio of electrolytes is
extremely important because every cell
in your body but especially your nerve
cells your neurons relies on
electrolytes in order to function
properly so when you're well hydrated
and you have the appropriate amount of
electrolytes in your system your mental
functioning and your physical
functioning is improved I drink one
packet of element dissolved in about 16
to 32 ounces of water when I wake up in
the morning as well as while I exercise
and if I've sweat a lot during that
exercise I often will drink a third
element packet dissolved in about 32
ounces of water after I exercise element
comes in a variety of different flavors
all of which I find really tasty I like
the Citrus I like the watermelon I like
the raspberry frankly I can't pick just
one it also comes in chocolate and
chocolate mint which I find tastes best
if they are put into water dissolved and
then heated up I tend to do that in the
winter months because of course you
don't just need hydration on hot days
and in the summer and spring months but
also in the winter when the temperatures
are cold and the environment tends to be
dry if you'd like to try element you can
go to drink element spelled
el.com huberman to try a free sample
pack again that's drink element.com
huberman we talked about dessert for
breakfast in the the form of cereals
some of which are um disguised or
couched as healthier you know I think of
like honeynut Cheerios it seems
healthier than Froot Loops it looks
healthier like the just by way of color
it looks kind of weedy you know color so
but let and in terms of lunch I mean one
of the things that I love about Europe
is that the breads are amazing yeah
breads are terrific there and I like
them because they're not as sweet
exactly and so a sandwich from not every
Deli but from a typical sandwich shop or
that one makes with store-bought bread
sliced bread in the US has a lot of
fructose I looked I looked this up prior
to to our discussion today so in some
ways dessert is being woven into foods
that
are that parents Andor kids everyone
thinks our Savory are we're actually
eating sweets exactly right but we can't
but we don't taste them as sweet at a
conscious level necessarily right but
our but our taste buds do right that's
exactly right so the question is why do
they do that so
question for your audience you buy a
loaf of bread at the local bakery how
soon before it stales two days at best
yeah if it's really grap bread that's
right the better the bread the quicker
it
stals you buy a loaf of bread at the uh
Neighborhood Grocery Store how soon
before it stales w you've got probably a
week and then there's the moldy pieces
at the end that you try you know if
you're in college and me try and scrape
that off um but can last up to 3 weeks
depending right you could throw it in
the freezer you probably do that with
the bakery bread but it's never the same
never the same it's never the same so
the question is why is that and the
answer is
sugar the answer is sugar so the grocery
store bread had sugar added to it on
purpose because when you bake it the
sugar does not evaporate it stays in the
bread and the sugar is hygroscopic
meaning it holds holds on to water this
is a phenomenon that the food industry
uses called water activity okay and so
it will hold on to water and so it will
stay spongy and it will not stale as
quickly as the bakery store bread which
did not have that sugar added to it so
even something as benign as bread has
been turned into something that
ultimately leads to Chronic metabolic
disease we've pivoted somewhat from
carbohydrate divided in to GL glucose
and fructose to a discussion of sugar
could you tell us the link between sugar
and fructose so table sugar what
percentage of table sugar is fructose
what percentage of brown sugar is
fructose what percentage of the sugar
that's added to food is high fructose
corn syrup on average you know just
because here what we're talking about is
um what you're describing as an
intentional lacing of food with
something that's addictive but that's
also processed very differently at the
level of the kidney at the level of the
liver um right
and it's bad it's a bad it's a bad
situation so when we talk about sugar I
think we need to be as careful in
describing what we really mean as when
we talk about a calorie I completely
agree so let for your audience let's be
very very clear on definitions okay
let's not use the word sugar because it
has multiple
definitions let's use
sucrose sucrose is what you put in your
coffee it's the crystals all right it's
cane sugar Beach
sugar you know the you know the stuff
that teaspoons of right this was all
that was available for many many
years that is one molecule of
glucose one molecule of fructose bound
together uh for the chemists out there
an Oly acidic linkage
okay the enzyme in your intestine called
sucra Cleaves this glycosidic linkage in
about a nanc you absorb the two
molecules separately the glucose goes to
the entire body generates an insulin
response the fructose goes straight to
your liver generates
fat that's sucrose high fructose corn
syrup is essentially one molecule
glucose one molecule of fructose not
bound together no Oly acidic linkage so
they're
free the enzyme sucra doesn't care
because the blond's already
broken ultimately they do the same thing
and that's why high fructose corn syrup
and sucrose are indistinguishable
metabolically what they are is they're
very different economically and the
reason is because high fructose corn
serbs half the price of sucrose because
sucrose we get from importing and high
fructose corn Sy we make it
home sucrose is in bags high fructose
corn syrup is in barrels sucrose you can
sell at the store high fructose corn
syrup you sell to the you know ultr
processed food manufacturer you can't
buy high fructose corn syrup at the uh
you know at the grocery store so they're
very different in terms of what they're
used for high corn syrup is particularly
egregious because it's so missable
because it's already a liquid so you've
probably remember chips aoy cookies in
the old days okay they would often would
seem like the sugar in the uh cookie had
crystallized cu the sugar content was so
high it's been a while since I've had
one they weren't particularly good yeah
but you eat two of them and then you
think they're good and then you want to
eat four that's what so odd the first
bite is kind of like and then it bombs
away there you go well now it's a chewy
Chips of Hoy cookies oh I remember the
chew chips remember chewy Chips well
that that's high fructose corn syrup
because because the two molecules are
free they don't crystallize so you can
actually up the dose several times
throughout today's discussion you've
been talking about the quote unquote
food industry mhm okay so I'm not a
conspiracy theorist I am but I now but I
understand um you know that most
businesses exist to make money yeah many
businesses start off with good
intentions and drift in order to stay um
to stay competitive um and many many
businesses as we know um not all of
which are entirely bad such as the
pharmaceutical industry right you
they're bad they're instances of like
the opioid crisis but then there are
drugs from the pharmaceutical industry
that help save lives I mean that's my my
stance um the food industry I think they
are good actors and there are Bad actors
but we're talking about the food
industry okay well we talk about the
exercise industry we talk about the
podcast industry I mean you got good
actors and Bad actors but but what
you've alluded to several times here and
you're more informed than I am is a uh
a concerted effort to lace food with a
form of sugar that makes people crave
more of that food and that is causing
metabolic illness disrupting
mitochondria and on and on exactly and
you're the physician not me um you've
worked with patients who struggle with
obesity and for various reasons um not
me and um so we could probably spend
hours if not days talking about all the
terrible things that the quote unquote
food industry has done but what do you
think is the the pure pure motivation
right I don't think that they want
people to be sick but they want to sell
product and this sells more product so
then it raises two
questions if why is it that more people
don't know about know this information
although many more will know after
today's conversation but and certainly
in government it's it's a mix regardless
of what side of the aisle you're on or
if you're right in between they're
they're clearly people that care about
the health of themselves and others
so I can understand how things might
have gotten to this point but what do
you think are the barriers to getting
people to appreciate just what a problem
this is and and getting people to change
their choices in terms of what they're
eating are they truly addicted to the
point where they are sick they can't
make good decisions like a like a drug
addict who's highly addicted to heroin
is a sick person they have an illness
and they need treatment but until they
get that treatment they can't make good
decisions let's take an analogy
alcohol 40% of Americans are tea tolers
never touch the stuff 40% don't drink
40% don't drink great I'm not a big fan
of alcohol I've never seen it make
anyone better at anything that really
mattered no because except drinking and
matter completely vestigal there's no uh
biochemical reaction in the body that
requires alcohol okay for the same
reason by the way
fructose um 40% are social drinkers you
know you can pick up a beer put it down
I'm in that category 10% % are binge
Drinkers and 10% are chronic
alcoholics okay now do you
deprive the 40% of social drinkers
because of the
20% of binge Drinkers and chronic
alcoholics no I believe people should be
in choice but I believe people should
know what they are doing so that they
can be in Choice well right like do as
you I always say uh and I said this
about the alcohol episode which turned
out to be one of our most prolific Epis
episodes where I said you know more than
two drinks zero is better than any and
more than two drinks per week you need
to do other things to offset that and
it's problematic that's what those are
what the data say but I but I would say
do as you want but know what you're
doing well so I would say that that's
exactly what the food industry wants you
to think that's that is the food
industry's Mantra is you have your own
choice personal
responsibility so the question is does
personal responsibility work and the
answer is no it doesn't
every uh Public Health debacle in the
history of mankind started out as a
personal health issue before it became a
Public Health crisis and you can pick
your uh you know personal responsibility
issue whether it be exposures whether it
be addictions whether it be
infections bottom line is ultimately it
required a societal response okay we can
talk about syphilis we can talk about
tuberculosis ultimately needed a public
health response we can talk about um uh
teen pregnancy we can talk about tobacco
tobacco ultimately needs a public health
response because the sheer enormity of
it and the uh the egregiousness of it
requires that public health response
Well turns out this is no
different in order to exercise personal
responsibility four criteria have to be
met those four criteria are the
following number one knowledge you have
to have the knowledge because if you
don't have the knowledge then how can
you exercise personal responsibility
well in fact the Public's being kept
from the knowledge we're doing this now
in part to in you know to entrain that
knowledge to to get people to understand
what the problem is yeah I mean I
consider myself pretty informed about
nutrition and health but
already today I've learned two dozen
facts about processing of fructose and
calories generally that I had no
knowledge of Prior well that's good okay
because it's not about the math it's
about the science okay they want it to
be about calories so we have this thing
called food science we have this thing
called nutrition and we have this thing
called metabolic Health they are not the
same food science is what happens to
food between the ground and the mouth
nutrition is what happens to food
between the mouth and the cell metabolic
health is what happens to food inside
the cell but all of the chronic diseases
that we are suffering from type two
diabetes hypertension dyslipidemia
cardiovascular disease cancer dementia
fatty liver disease polycystic ovarian
disease those eight diseases which make
up 75% of healthc care expenditures in
this country
today are all inside the cell because
they are all mitochondrial dysfunction
and there is no medicine that gets to
the mitochondria although you and others
at Stanford Harvard Etc are starting
this with the metabolic Psychiatry being
one instance righted and UCSF as well
forgive me I should mentioned UCSF up
front your your home institution
wonderful institution right up the road
from Stanford so you know things are
changing people are starting to think
about mitochondrial Health they are okay
so you list off the first the first
thing and you said there are four things
that stand is be first one was knowledge
okay second access
because if you don't have access then
how can you exercise personal
responsibility access to healthier
Alternatives exactly which means cost
effective I mean I love berries from the
farmers market more than I love berries
from the store I love the farmers
markets generally but it takes time
energy to go there and the costs are
actually lower at the level of what you
hand the vendor typically right but uh
volume is tough to achieve right they
actually have me at a at a quota I'm not
not allowed to buy as many berries as I
want because obviously there are other
people who want berries so there's that
right people have to feed their family
that you know and they want we're used
to eating a lot of volume but you're
able to at least go there sometimes okay
yeah we're talking about people who live
in quote food deserts we're also talking
about people who live in food swamps
okay when we're talking about food
swamps we're not talking about an
plethora of healthy foods we're talking
about all the junk that's what they they
live in the swamp of junk so
if you live in the swamp of junk how are
you supposed to exercise personal
responsibility number three uh or
affordability so you have to be able to
afford your choice and Society has to be
able to afford your choice and right now
we can't afford that choice
because health care costs right now are
at $4.1 trillion a year but like so many
things in uh behavioral economics and
health it's so hard for people to see
that the the immediate choice is leading
to a higher cost down the road there
just too many nodes of separation for
people to realize hey when I'm reaching
for this cereal as opposed to making
waffles for my kids from scratch or you
know they're thinking time efficiency
cost efficiency volume the kids's not
throwing Tantrums because they're not no
longer getting the cereal and it's a
very difficult to see this is the reason
why healthc care costs are going up
there just too many nodes of separation
wouldn't agree more but the ultimately
it's because the government separates
and
silos um food industry profits from
health care costs if you actually
combine those because they ultim are the
same you would see the problem so
globally the food industry grosses $9
trillion a year health care cost
globally cost1 trillion a year dietary
related health costs environmental costs
cost $7 trillion a year and productivity
costs cost $1 trillion a year so when
you do the math 9 - 11 - 7 -1 means that
there is a 10 trillion a year
deficit because of us cleaning up the
mess that the food industry makes and
while numbers like that that's not
affordable right I agree and while
numbers like that land really hard I
find that for myself and for many people
statistics like that are hard to keep in
mind in a way there's something about
the human brain that hears that and goes
whoa we're like that War cost that much
and this food issue costs that much and
then we go to the store and we're hungry
right and the kids are are are are
hungry and and you're and so those nodes
of Separation it's it's almost like a
neural SL memory SL prefrontal cortex
issue to me and of course I look at
everything through the lens of
neurobiology you know not everything but
most everything and so how how could I
not how could we not but then like the
issue is well there's still food on the
shelves and you know and so it's very
what do we do to connect to bring closer
together these notes what would the
government do so the question is is
there food on the shelves let me finish
the fourth one and then I want to come
back to that point let me just you know
finish a concept so affordability and
number four externalities your choice
can't hurt anybody else but what if your
choice does hurt somebody else so like
for tobacco secondhand smoke right for
alcohol drunk driving what was the
argument for teen pregnancy that someone
else was going to have to raise the kids
exactly all right but what about for
food okay well how about the fact that
your employer Stanford University has to
pay
$2,750 uh per year in obesity related
health care expenses that they have
passed on to you even though you're not
obese that is affecting you so that
guy's obesity right there that is
affecting you ah but there nowadays it's
especially tricky even to have the
conversation I'm willing to have it now
which is that you know there's this
whole concept of fat shaming right so if
somebody's obese whose fault is it and
if we even talk about it is uh are we
subject to um attack legitimate attack
you know so like so calling something o
o someone obese at a clinical level like
I mean you're an expert
iny don't talk about obesity let's talk
about diabetes okay so talk about
consequence of obesity yeah let's talk
about the metabolic health issue
itself okay the fact is that diabetes is
now
11.4% of America what was it 20 years
ago it was 20 years ago it was about 8%
I was wondering this earlier 20 years
ago there was a lot more margarine in
refrigerators but people were thinner
and there was less diabetes everything
you told us about margarine and trans
fats is that it's bad bad bad now butter
is back as Time Magazine and you said
right so clearly can't be the transition
away from trans fats that's increased
obesity well no no so it's going to be
the increase in sugar and increase in
sugar and these hidden sugars in exactly
that's right all right the the the the
key though is Pakistan and India because
uh and China they are not fat but they
have 14% diabetes rates and they're thin
and the reason is because of ultr
processed food are there any countries
in the
world that don't allow high fructose
corn syrup or at least not at the level
that that we do oh the fre boats okay
there are boatloads of countries that uh
don't don't import high fructose corn
syrup or don't make it so uh
Scandinavian countries Scandinavian
countries most of Europe um the other
than the asia-pacific rim so uh Japan
has it in fact it was invented in Japan
1966 Saga medical school
takasaki at all um uh Korea has it um
but Australia does not have it Thailand
does not have it but they have just as
much of an uh obesity and diabetes
problem as we do because they have
sucrose
because hypose corn syrup and sucrose
are no different metabolically so it
doesn't really matter is that one to one
it's one to one thing exactly of glucose
and fructose so here's the question
Andrew okay so I want to go back to that
you said all this food is still on the
shelves is it food what is the
definition of
food can I give the definition I think
most people would give that's not
necessarily the one I would I would give
but um
something that has contains caloric
energy right like I I could eat this
microphone um but it's not going to
provide much useful energy the
definition of food straight from the
dictionary and believe me I looked it up
and memorized it I believe you substrate
that contributes to either growth or
burning of an organism interesting that
is the definition of food I'm free
scientific for
100% correct growth or burning so any
substrate that passes your lips that
contributes to either growth or burning
that's food okay let's do it let's do
burning first I just showed you that
Sugar which is the marker of ultra
processed food and 73% of the items in
the grocery store are spiked with sugar
inhibits burning it inhibits those three
enzymes involved in mitochondrial
function now let's do growth my
colleague Dr arrat maneno Oran who is
was the chairman of nutrition at Hebrew
University
Jerusalem actually looked at this
question and showed that Ultra processed
food actually inhibits growth it
inhibits cortical bone growth it
inhibits uh tricular bone growth it
inhibits uh cancelous bone growth it
inhibits linear bone growth it hijacks
growth for cancer because it inhibits
mitochondria and so you have to then
grow instead of burn and this was work
that was done in in Vivo or in vitro inv
Vivo inv Vivo so these are people that
are eating high amounts of Highly
processed food exactly how did he find
those in in the in the Middle
East they they found in Israel they
found it so the bottom line is if a
substrate does not contribute to growth
and does not contribute to burning is it
a
food I the answer is no well that's 73%
of what's in the grocery store so I
would argue you said the food food's
there no it's not that's not food in
fact it's consumable poison so this
leads to an important question of what's
left right you remove all that what's
left um just anecdotally and what I
sometimes call anec Dat um you know I've
had several friends in their 40s and
early 50s say they wanted to lose weight
and get in shape and the the thing
that's worked every every single time
for them to lose significant amounts of
weight quickly and keep it off and many
of them were already exercising but then
also increase their exercise was I just
since I'm not a dietitian nutritionist
or anything I just say eat meat fish
eggs vegetables fruits you're not going
to eat starches you're not going to
drink alcohol you're not going to drink
soda you can still have coffee tea you
can still have artificial sweeteners I
we go get to artificial sweeters in a
little bit we have to go there but um
and the reason I say no starches even
though I personally eat rice oatmeal
pasta things of that sort some in in
moderation depending on on what sort of
exercise and I'm doing and how much is
because of the fact that nowadays many
of those things contain fructose and
inevitably every one of those people is
blown away by the fact that it quote
unquote works and assumes that it's all
because of reduced calorie intake
overall and they lose like anywhere from
30 to 55 pound and keep it off and they
like hey this is great I can actually
still eat riye steaks and salads and but
they're not eating croutons they're and
so in some sense it looks extreme it
sounds ketogenic but it's nothing like
that you're just saying basically stay
away from you're eliminating processed
foods you're eliminating liquid calories
in in general you and on and on and so
there's nothing sophisticated about it
and my question to you is how much of
that weight loss effect do you think is
calories in versus calories out out
effect because they're eating a lot of
food and in some cases and how much of
it do you think is the elimination or
near elimination of this fructose or
this glucose fructose combination it's
nothing to do with the calories it has
everything to do with the
insulin if you get the insulin down
you're not shunting energy to Fat you
can lose weight your
fat will give up
it the ad the uh the triglyceride stored
in it as soon as your insulin goes down
insulin is pushing on your fat cell all
the time and as long as your insulin's
up your fat cell can't release it the
minute your insulin goes down you can
now engage in what we call lipolysis
hormone sensitive lipase is a an enzyme
in the fat cell that is U inhibited by
insulin as soon as the insulin's gone
hormone sensitive lipase can turn that
stored triglyceride into free fatty
acids and glycerol and release it and
you can lose weight so get the insulin
down and it all works so the question is
what makes insulin go up well two things
refine carbohydrate and sugar those are
the two things that make insulin go up
in addition Branch chain amino acids
make insulin go up as well Lucine
isoline veine which is in cornfed beef
chicken and fish processed food all
right here's here's here's the deal in
one concept my colleague Dr Carlos
Montero who is a professor of Public
Health at the University of sa Paulo has
done the world a great service he has
developed a system for categorization of
food processing it is called the Nova
System just means new but he has
basically categorized every
food anywhere in the world into one of
four
classes easiest way to explain this
would be an example let's take an
apple Nova class one would be an apple
picked off a tree Nova class two would
be apple slices D stem deed deskinned
maybe Nova class 3 would be
applesauce cooked mated possibly at
preservative added maybe some extra
sugar maybe not Nova class 4 would be
McDonald's apple
pie now does that McDonald's apple pie
look anything like that Apple no is
there even any Apple in it maybe a tiny
bit maybe not maybe a tiny bit you know
it's it's all flavor enhanced Etc okay
turns out and this is epidemiologic data
but nonetheless prospective
epidemiologic data so it's not
useless that Nova class 4 that ultr
processed food category which is 7 3% of
the American grocery
store is the class that is associated
with all of these chronic metabolic
diseases Nova class 1 through three no
problem now when you say associate what
percentage of one's daily total caloric
intake needs to come from Nova class 4
before that statement you just made is
true because it I love the
recommendation you made earlier or the
let's just say the the Contour of a you
don't have to
avoid dessert you can enjoy dessert but
don't eat dessert at other times of day
right and maybe you don't eat dessert
every single night right I is there a
rule that people have to eat dessert
every single night so the answer is
about 7 to
10% would be the upper limit so you can
get 7 to 10% of your caloric intake
daily caloric intake from these Nova
class 4 foods and still still be okay
and still be okay yeah so this is I know
but that's not what's happening right I
know some very healthy Physicians who I
used to um observe how people ate and
moved because I I would pay attention in
my in our field right I I was like oh
you know people all around me at
Stanford UCSF ET were successful or else
they wouldn't be there I was like you
know who looks healthy who can make it
up the stairs and doesn't have to take
the elevator how much exercise are
people doing at a given age are they
fanatic you know like four in the
morning Runners I'm not going to do that
consistently unless I have to um and and
I observed that you know many of the
healthiest people I know they move a lot
during the day they ate very well many
of them skip breakfast or lunch not
always and then I also noticed that they
would drink very little or no alcohol
and then but they would enjoy like a uh
there's one physician at UCSF in
particular I'm thinking of who really
enjoyed his dark chocolate Kit Kat after
lunch and he sort of very um ceremonial
about the unraveling of that uh the foil
and you and it was like okay so you're
talking about that small percentage of
calories if that if that's if that's all
you do hey you know God bless you but
that's not what people are doing that's
the problem bottom line that Nova class
4 is where all the action is in terms of
chronic metabolic disease so the
question is how can you avoid that how
do you know which is which we have a
solution so my colleagues and I have
developed a web-based tool that is
available to the entire world right now
and you'll put it in your show notes
yeah we'll put a link to this absolutely
it's called perfect p r f a and you can
find it at perfect.
Co and what it is is it's a
recommendation
engine not AI we're going to talk about
AI in a minute but it is a
recommendation engine based on the
science of human
metabolism that categorizes Foods based
on not their nutrients content but on
their Metabolic Effect interesting and
so there is a Nova filter which will
filter out all the Nova class 4 stuff
and it will go to your grocery
store and will tell you what you can buy
that will be a Nova class 1 through
three which turns out to only be 20% of
the grocery store it means basically
staying on the periphery of the grocery
store right general in general the
produce the meat the dairy the all the
things
mentioned in fact so I'm not low carb
I'm low insulin and there are a lot of
ways to get to low insulin get rid of
the refined carbohydrate get rid of the
sugar increase the fiber get rid of the
branch chain amino acids okay so eating
fish is a good place to be um even
eating a steak is okay if it's a uh
pasture fed steak so let's talk about
your steak which is also better for the
animals right it is absolutely so you
mentioned marbling before we love our
marbling right we can cut our us grade A
steaks with a butter knife because
they're so tender right you ever been to
Argentina yeah my father's argentin oh
right that's right you're Argentinian
yeah they only know they only know grass
F steak the only the idea that that cows
would eat anything but grass is sort of
like the idea that um fish would would
would fly absolutely New Zealand same
thing yeah okay the meat is gorgeous
it's homogeneous it's pink it's
delightful I've been to Argentina the
meat is fantastic but you have to use a
steak Knife you can't use a butter knife
and it takes more chewing it and it
takes more chewing because there's senu
there you know it's a it's a different
experience entirely it's delicious but
it is kind of a little bit you know
tougher all right turns out that
marbling is intramyocellular
lipid that animal has metabolic syndrome
the American cornfed the American
cornfed animal because that corn is
filled with Branch chain amino acids
Lucine isoline veine Branch chain amino
acids are what's in protein powder
that's what um you know bodybuilders you
know put in their smoothies you know to
build muscle and if you're building
muscle that's okay because 20% of the
amino acids in muscle are Branch chain
um so you know if you've got a place to
put them you know have at it yeah
there's a need there cuz they're down
musle yeah fine but if you're not if
you're you know again a mere mortal like
me you consume those excess branchin
amino acids they're going to go to the
liver they're going to be deamidated
like we talked about earlier and they're
going to end up as Branch chain organic
acids they're going to flood the
mitochondria the mitochondria are not
going to be able to deal with the volume
and so they're going to divert the
excess and turn that into fat and so now
you've got hyper
triglyceridemia and chance for fatty
liver disease
and insulin resistance
so what kind of meat you eat has a lot
to do with your metabolic Health what
about the egg the whole egg near near
perfect protein score in terms of its um
uh
bioavailability um eggs are terrific
okay there's nothing wrong with eggs now
there are better eggs than others so
there so well there's yellow uh yolk
eggs and there are orange yolk eggs
what's the difference between a yellow
Oak egg and an orange Oak egg I'm
guessing that something about the uh the
feed of the the mother chicken um and
I'm guessing it probably also has
something to do with choline content
Omega-3s ah interesting okay the orange
uh yolk egg has a lot of Omega-3s in it
what are other great sources of Omega-3s
I I I know some off the top of my head
but I'd like to hear it from you okay so
marine life is number number one okay um
you know fish provided you're not
bringing in heavy metals with it well
yes so I mean that's always the the the
argument you know the question is you
know is it the Mercury or is it the
Omega-3s ultimately I think it's the
Omega-3s that is more important but yes
I do understand the Mercury issue um uh
ultimately there are three Omega-3s
there's ala alpha linolenic acid which
you can get in vegetables there is EPA
eicosapentanoic acid which you can only
get in marine life fish oil cod liver
oil right and finally DHA dooh heex
enoic acid which you also get from
marine life but you can get from algae
so you can get algal oil which you know
the vegans will use do you um personally
take anything to increase your omega-3
intake I I know that there's even
prescription Omega-3s I take fish oil
you take a fish o yeah uh the the thres
I only take three I only take three
supplements okay I'd like to know what
those are I will say that I always
always always say behaviors first right
dos and don'ts behaviors
nutrition then only if needed and one
can afford it then supplementation and
prescription drugs and I'm a big
consumer of supplements and always have
been frankly so what are the three so
you take fish oil fish oil and do you
take to get above a certain threshold of
EPA about a th000 milligrams say about a
gram a day OFA okay uh vitamin C how
much vitamin C do you a th000 milligrams
a day you line is Pauling yeah well it's
actually for my rosacea I've got the um
skin issue and vitamin C helps with
helps with that interesting and finally
vitamin D now I will tell you vitamin D
is a complicated one all right uh let
and we can talk about vitamin D and how
either important or non-important it is
because there's a there's a quirk to
vitamin D and uh uh it it's important
for your audience to know about it
because everybody in his brother's you
know touting vitamin D a cure for
everything it's sort of funny because
that you have your supplement lovers
haters and agnostics but vitamin D
somehow made it through the shoot like
everyone's like Pro vitamin D it's
really interesting somehow vitamin D
people are comfortable taking a gel a
vitamin D gel cap but like other
supplements where you say oh like maybe
um this might be good for uh you know
like Omega-3s and fish them people are a
little bit like more standoff it's
really interesting that the kind of
psychos social stuff around this how
much vitamin D do you personally take I
take 5,000 units a day okay so do I
vitamin D is complicated though here's
the problem if you look at the
literature vitamin D deficiency is
associated with all these chronic
metabolic
diseases however
supplementation with vitamin D has not
fixed any of
those so so if you're vitamin D
deficient why wouldn't supplementation
fix
it couple of reasons one one of the
reasons for vitamin D deficiency is
because everyone's drinking soft drinks
that's one reason but there's a more
important reason uh sugar and
artificially sweetened soft drinks yeah
can deplete vitamin D utiliz well you're
not consuming Dairy because you're
consuming soft drinks but I can't
tolerate milk anymore well then you take
vitamin D but here's the here's the real
nugget of Truth and this is a little
complicated but the endocrinologists and
the audience will get
it vitamin D is a pre-pro hormone it's
not it's not active at all vitamin D is
converted in the liver first step to a
compound called 25 hydroxy vitamin D
that is a pro hormone it also is
inactive it has no activity whatsoever
from there 25 hydroxy vitamin D can be
metabolized one of two
ways it can either be one alpha
hydroxylated in the kidney to the active
form one Alpha One 25 dihydroxy vitamin
D which will then do all of the business
of vitamin D such as calcium absorption
from the gut suppression of the immune
system at the toll like receptor 4 that
sounds like a bad thing no that's a good
thing I know but I had to bring that up
because when you say suppression of the
immune system people go I'm
immunosuppressed nobody that sounds like
AIDS a good it suppresses inflammation
got it it's a good thing okay
suppression of inflammation and that's
actually the point that we're we're
getting to so there are a lot of good
things about 125 dihydroxy vitamin
D however that 25 hydroxy D that came
out of the liver can be metabolized a
different way it can be 20 for
hydroxy in inflammatory
tissue like tuberculosis
sarcoid gut
inflammation and so you will end up
taking your 25 hydroxy D which is a pro
hormone and turning it into the inactive
2425 dihydroxy D which then just gets
excreted out so in other words you
consumed all this vitamin D and it
didn't go where you needed it to go and
the reason was because you're
inflamed you have to fix the
inflammation before the vitamin D can be
effective and 93% of Americans are
inflamed so giving them vitamin D is not
going to do a damn thing got it is
reducing fructose intake the one of the
primary ways to reduce systemic
inflammation absolutely what are some
others reducing oxidative stress in
general so heavy metals like cadmium you
know cadmium is very high in chocolate
especially South American chocolate
sorry no I I'm not a fan of chocolate I
occasionally like a little dark
chocolate but okay but um so if people
are going to eat chocolate they should
be careful how much chocolate they eat
well especially if it's South American
chocolate and processed chocolate I mean
the really good we're going to be on the
hit list of so many Industries after
this episode comes out all I can tell
you is I've been on the hit list for a
decade and I'm still here you're you're
just one big Target yeah right got it I
got to I it's my back you know kick me I
already got that um uh there are uh uh
the main thing is to make that gut work
right so fiber short chain fatty acid
production from fiber uh is a huge you
know uh Boon and reduce inflammation to
reduce inflammation how about improving
sleep is there any evidence that you
know chronic slight sleep deprivation
can increase inflammation well what it
will do is it'll increase cortisol and
chronically increased cortisol will
definitely lead to increased
inflammation you know which is funny
because cortisols usually considered the
anti-inflammatory but only acutely right
chronic cortisol elevation does the
opposite if if we can contribute to I
have this secret uh agenda which is not
which is not a secret which is that
people think cortisol is bad when in
fact acutely cortisol does wonderful
things provided it's happening at the
right time of day right late shifted
cortisol bad right too much or too
frequent cortisol bad but cortisol you
you need it it's so essential and I
think most people just hear cortisol and
it's been associated with all things bad
and and maybe we can help shift that
narrative yeah I'm I'm very happy I mean
as an endocrinologist you know this is
you know this my wheelhouse is where I
live um cortisol is a good news bad news
deal like so many things shortterm gain
for long-term pain okay so when you are
in what we call
allostasis that is perturbation of
homeostasis that is a stress an acute
stress cortisol is one of the things
that helps you manage that bodily and
mental stress so an English
test a car accident running away from
the lion you know the famous you know
pyg me running away from the lion all of
those require cortisol in in order to
manage and mitigate that stress the
upcoming 2024 election that's chronic
stress that is not acute stress mean to
that's the worst that'll be the only
mention of Politics on this podcast uh
and we don't have to go there but we're
all chronically stressed and we can talk
about why that is and what's going on
and I'm actually very interested in that
and a colleague of mine in Paris and I
have built a computational model of the
lyic system which focuses on the stress
center of the brain the amydala to
understand how chronic stress is
different from acute stress and how that
chronic stress ultimately leads to
metabolic and mental health disaster
very interested in learning more about
that before we touch on that you've
worked a lot with kids MH um people age
as you put it 0 to
19 I don't know about
the exact numbers but when I was growing
up there were some kids in school that
were overweight but it was the
occasional kid right now it seems
depending on where one draws the
threshold for overweight it seems that
there are a lot of kids that are
overweight um how about 25%
obese and 40% overweight okay so
obviously a serious problem Ser now and
going forward what about adults in the
US um I remember seeing at a meeting a
map of obesity in the US and um over
time and it very quickly filled in from
very few people were obese to very many
Colorado was this um was this like like
Beacon of of of fit people but now it's
no longer and that's too oh
okay cool I'll tell you why there there
are four things that can increase
mitochondrial uh uh uh biogenesis are
you going to tell me altitude is one
cold yeah that's why Colorado is less
obese altitude that's why Colorado is
less obese
and um uh what were the other two I for
but those were the reason it had nothing
to do with being more fit it had to do
with cold and altitude example
Switzerland compared to Germany they got
the same crappy food but Switzerland has
half the Obesity that Germany does
because Switzerland is higher oh I love
the food when I go to Munich I love the
Schnitzel and wonder sourkrauts and they
got that in Switzerland too okay so they
have great food Switzerland's less obese
right same way Colorado is less obese
it's because of the altitude you you
mentioned cold U many listeners of this
podcast are at least interested in some
uh also practice deliberate cold
exposure cold showers cold plunges
mainly for the um I think the best data
are the increases in catac colam Mees
epinephrine norepinephrine dopamine that
are long- lasting people feel a big
state shift they feel better yeah but
when one looks at the effects on
metabolism they're pretty slight they
are they're slight however studies like
that to me always seem um shortsighted
in the sense that if there's a longer
Arc of effect on the mitochondria that's
affecting other things in terms of how
calories are
processed or how calories are feeding
into mitochondrial function or
dysfunction there I could see how it
might shift the um shift the scal so to
speak I mean cold is is an amazingly
powerful stimulus it and um I think of
light cold food movement it's kind of
like the core four ways in which you can
shift physiology easily all of these
things are eminently manipulable and for
almost zero dollars okay but you have to
know what you're doing and right now
we've been actually kept from that
knowledge and you know if you're
addicted it's really hard to un addict
yourself so that brings us back to this
thing about
um food industry conspiracies government
conspiracy and the rest boy this is
going to be an interesting um we can go
uh section
but what do we do like so if you and I
go up to cap capitol hill which I've
done yeah which you've done and and
maybe I'll join you someday
um and you know you're UCSF I'm down at
Stanford you're a clinician I'm a
scientist and and a public health
Advocate um podcaster right and we
explain to people Hey listen like
there's the food is laced with a drug
it's it's it's not even really food it's
not it's an aggregate of food and non-f
food parts that make you think it's food
it's sort of like telling people hey
your kids are you know they're swimming
in a swimming pool looks like water but
it's actually part poison and it's and
it's harming them it's giving them you
know if you say those kinds of things I
mean congressmen and women are they're
like reasonably smart people right I
mean AR aren't they going to do
something about it no so where is the
conflict is it that the food industry
has um the government by the short hairs
that's exactly right and they have them
by the short hairs where I mean is it
are they lining their pockets I mean
where where where is The Leverage ACC
actually exerted okay so they're they
are lining their pockets that's number
one that is absolutely true we have the
data to support that blanch Lincoln who
was a senator from Arkansas who was the
chairman of the nutrition committee you
had to see her campaign contributions
every time she was up for re-election so
it's all about getting reelected or it's
about them like having a like a third
home in the Hamptons so I think it's the
third home in the
more than anything wow okay so it's
really as bad as as as some of the
documentaries make us believe without
question goodness and we and we and we
have the data there is a uh uh an
organization that I absolutely want to
call out because they are you know the
most egregious organ you political
organization on the face of the Earth
they're called the American legislative
exchange Council Alec or alic and they
write bills they are a bill Mill okay
and they for whoever gives them money
and who gives them money big Pharma big
Agra big oil and uh big food and you're
so you're including big Pharma you're a
physician you've written scripts before
you've written prescriptions for
patients before isn't that Pharma that
provides the drugs that allows your
patients to feel better well the
question is do they do they feel better
this is a big question let's you want to
go you're writing but you're writing the
script I mean I mean I'm just trying I'm
not trying to try to challenge you but I
see so so you don't uh there have to be
instances where someone's thyroid
deficient and you give them you know a
drug AB so if so if if you've got a
disease and a medicine will replace
what's missing sure okay so for
deficiency diseases which as an
endocrinologist that's what I do
absolutely and I did that you know with
no compunction of uh of impropriety
whatsoever but that's not what we're
talking about here let's talk about
we're really talking about let's start
with
stattin Statin lower
LDL okay does statins reduce heart
disease yes or
no you know I seem to be whiffing today
on all the quizzes and it's kind of
becoming fun for me at this level I'm
going to go with no but but I will say
you know my friend and I think his
expert uh physician as well you know
Peter AA and others you know has talked
about some of the positive attributes of
statens in certain cases for certain
Pati in certain cases that's exactly
right and I completely agree and by the
way Peter's a friend and you know we
someday we'll we'll you know all you
know go out drinking together well I
won't drink but how about we share a
steak share a absolutely you got it you
guys I don't I don't know if he drink he
drinks a little bit if if you're
listening okay he drinks a little bit
house on me yeah I don't do the dessert
or the or the alcohol anymore but but
I'm and it's not so I can live to be 120
it's so I can wake up the next morning
and and uh keep up with you guys it's
fine I get the so for primary prevention
that is your LDL is high you need a
Statin that's primary prevention you
haven't declared yourself you haven't
had an event for primary prevention the
mean increase in lifespan for being on a
Statin is four days four days four days
four days so to chuckle that's that's uh
and the risk for
diabetes is 20% increase what about any
Improvement in in quality of life none
for primary prevention now for secondary
prevention for secondary in other words
you've already declared yourself you
already have a problem for secondary
prevention that's where Statin shine so
there's a value to them I'm not arguing
that and if you have familial hyper
cholesterolemia which is one in 500 okay
not do you need a Statin but you need a
lowfat diet and a
priest okay so there is definitely a
value to stattin but not for primary
prevention but that's what everybody
what every doctor is doing oh your LDL
it's over 80 you know you need a Statin
that's ridiculous that is absolutely a
joke and the data show that in fact in
fact my colleague aim Malhotra in the UK
participated in an analysis where they
took the entire UK
population and they took out everybody
under age 65 so you're looking at people
65 to 90 and it turned out that the LDL
level correlated with longevity the
higher the LDL the longer they lived
when you took out all the people who had
problems so LDL is not really the
problem and the reason is because there
are two ldls there's one called large
buoyant there's one called small dents
turns out dietary fat raises your large
buoyant your large buoyant is
irrelevant it is
cardiovascularly neutral but that's the
one that statins
effects the small dense that's the
atherogenic particle when your small
dense LDL is high that means you are not
clearing triglyceride peripherally
because that's what small dense show you
that's that that's what happens to
triglyceride is become they become small
dense can I take a guess and say that
the best way to reduce small dens is to
reduce insulin yes by reducing
sugar because that triglyceride is made
in the liver it's all palmitate and
that's the only fat that the liver knows
how to make and so triglyceride is your
liver output of
carbohydrate that's how you have to look
at triglyceride so triglyceride turns
out to be much more important as a
cardiovascular risk factor than LDL ever
was so does the does big Pharma and big
food do they know all of this yes I know
they know because they've told me so and
but they have statins to
sell and Foods in the uh the Nova class
4 mhm they know this too so you know I'm
an optimist or you know what what's it
going to take to really move the needle
I mean you described the four barriers
um we're trying to add to the knowledge
component now um you know what's it
going to take is it going to take uh you
know having a president in office or a
congress people in office that really
understand and care about this
stuff yeah I mean to really revamp the
whole system yeah so right now the
system is completely and utterly broken
completely and utterly broken and
there's a reason why it's completely and
utterly broken because the food industry
likes it that way
well it's profitable for them obviously
there are 51 different federal agencies
that manage our food 51 and none of them
know what the other one's
doing and the food industry likes it
that way so communication across these
51 organizations would help well if we
had a centralized food um zor or food uh
you know if we split the food off the
FDA because you you know it's like it's
not the FDA it's the da or the FDA is
not the Food and Drug Administration
it's the Federal Drug Administration
they spend a lot of time on drugs they
spend almost no time on food well let's
think about where there's been success
so I can recall when people smoked on
planes I actually recall going to a gym
in Europe and there was an ashtray
molded into the squat rack yep that was
telling yeah I don't see people smoking
cigarettes around Stanford Hospital
anymore but I remember they initially
said that people couldn't smoke anywhere
except in this one little designated
area right and that's typically what you
see nowadays and my understanding of the
anti-smoking campaign at least for kids
for people 18 and younger was that
telling people it was bad for their
health didn't work showing them lungs
that were decrepit didn't work what
worked was showing them commercials of
cackling handw ring um white guys who
were talking about how much money they
were making off of these um uh naive
kids who were buying cigarettes and
other tobacco products so it became a
the the effective campaign to end
smoking in young people was to hijack
their re inherent rebelliousness of
Youth and then they were like no we're
not going to stick it to them like give
you know the the as my friend calls it
like the two the two-finger business
card like No And so that worked that
worked vaping is making a comeback we
vaping is a separate episode we won't
get into that but because nicotine is
still addictive but you don't see a lot
of people smoking cigarettes so it
worked like something that you would
never imagine could ever work worked
well so yes no I mean that's part of it
I'm not going to tell you that it's not
it is part of it um and we actually have
an example of how that could be applied
to another uh uh uh toxic substance
sugar we had Berkeley versus big soda
you know that's how Berkeley ended up
with its soda tax that dates back to
2015 the city of Berkeley city of
Berkeley it we just celebrated the
5-year anniversary of the Berkeley soda
tax and we've been able to actually
look just stational diabetes way down
obesity down slightly not a lot but a
little bit um cardiovascular disease
down Dean Schillinger and Chris Madson
at UCSF and UC Berkeley just presented
at San Francisco General just um three
weeks ago so a soda tax like the
cigarette tax just makes soda expensive
exactly so you're telling me that a can
of
Coke that I buy on shatak Avenue in
Berkeley costs more than a can of Coke
that I buy in on University Avenue in
pal Alto it does huh okay by by a dime
and that was and sufficient enough to to
create this kind of change well yes it
is money hurts because money hurts
exactly so
Andrew there have been four count them
four cultural tectonic shifts in America
in the last 30 years and they're all
undeniable here they are number one
bicycle helmets and seat bels oh yeah
everybody uses those two smoking in
public places Nobody Does that three uh
drunk driving hopefully fewer people are
doing that four condoms and bathrooms
condoms in bathrooms in bathrooms in
public bathrooms yeah you see those more
available okay yeah all right 30 years
ago if a legislator stood up in a state
house and proposed legislation for any
one of those four and I don't care if
it's an a state house or in Congress or
in Parliament or in the Duma or anywhere
else in the world okay they have gotten
laughed right out of town Nanny state
liberty interest get out of my kitchen
get out of my bathroom get out of my car
okay today they're all facts of
life right nobody's belly aching about
any of those the point is we were able
to solve those
for public health debacles how did we do
it how did we solve those four no one
could imagine that we would ever solve
smoking right but we did sort of I mean
we brought consumption down by half okay
that's pretty good when you think about
for an addictive sub how many fewer
people are dying of lung cancer nowadays
in the US um it's like 80% lower wow
well there's also been improvements in
treatment but yeah but no but it's it's
the in diagnosed with in inci incidence
gone down amazing okay because tobacco's
gone down so the question is how did
that happen the answer is very and why
did it take 30 years to do it we taught
the children the children grew up and
they
voted and the
naysayers are
dead that's how you make a cultural
tectonic
shift
so we now have this real food Movement
we have people who are arguing against
Ultra processed food we have kids who
are demanding different in their schools
and by the way what is the biggest fast
food
franchise in the United States I'm going
to get this wrong so try me again I
don't know I've never tried it but I've
heard of uh is it
Chick-fil-A nope is it McDonald I don't
know it is this nation's Public Schools
ah you can add up McDonald's Subway
Burger King
chickfila and uh Wendy's and every other
uh fast food franchise Jack in the Box
every fast food franchise in the entire
country and would only be
half our nation's Public Schools wow so
could you imagine a world where there
were no class three or class four Nova
Foods allowed in uh in public schools
and we're doing it so I am the chief
science officer of a nonprofit and put
this in the show notes called Eat Real
e.org and we have a new business model
propos Public
Schools so in
1971 the Department of Education issued
an administrative ordinance called
resolution
242 and they did this purely on monetary
is reasons this was under Nixon and what
this resolution 242 said was that all
School
cafeterias all throughout the country
had to make
book they had to basically cover their
costs they couldn't be lost leaders for
the school they had to fend for
themselves well this sent every food
service director in the country
scurrying for you know how am I going to
do this because I got all these you know
uh you know Lunch Ladies you know which
you know personnel and and food
preparation equipment and and and costs
you know that they're you know mounting
how am I going
to break even they couldn't do it so in
walks
you know aramar and Cisco and uh
Guggenheim and McDonald's and they say
hey we'll do it for you we'll provide
every kid in America with a nutritious
meal Every Single Day hot lunch well
they didn't say hot okay they just said
lunch okay nutritious they said
nutritious and I put that in air quotes
too because it wasn't
nutritious and here's the added benefit
you can take your food preparation fac
facilities and your um uh footprint in
the school and you can turn that into
classrooms cuz you're going to need them
and that was the goal because as soon as
you've moved the food preparation
facilities out of the school you are now
Hostage to the food industry for the
rest of your life uh and I could also
see how that allows room for them to use
these commoditized Foods foods that have
very long shelf life exactly right
because you want to make sure that you
know if you only sold um you know 2third
of the lunch that were prepared that on
next Tuesday after the weekend you could
still give them food that isn't moldy
exactly right and I will tell you so
that's how it happened and you can
actually Trace IQ scores and reading and
math scores in this country down from
1971 to
today when I went to school I was
allowed to get I called it hot lunch
because it was usually hot it was um
allowed to get the school lunch one day
a week one day a week the other days I
had to bring my lunch MH that one day
was pretty special like you felt like
you were getting a treat it was usually
like corn dog or a hamburger the
hamburger was pretty poultry but the um
it's a commoditized hamburger yeah
commoditized hamburger um you had to go
looking for the Patty portion um and the
bread was sweetened and so it was
different right but um I don't remember
nearly as much obesity I went to to high
school in the early 90s MH um so you're
saying that now if I went to a high
school it would be a lot more sodas and
donuts and pizza and got it yeah Pizza
is a vegetable didn't you know they
claim it's a vegetable Congress said
Pizza is a vegetable Amy kashar made
pizza a vegetable maybe they need their
eyes check because the biggest frozen
pizza uh uh uh producer is in Minnesota
I mean the ketchup is a vegetable was
was a was a stretch but at least it it
made sense on the Nova System of going
from tomato all the way to uh to uh
ketchup since high fructose corn syrup
is the primary ingredient in ketchup
indeed so the point is that our kids are
suffering under the weight the burden of
this chronic disaster of ultra processed
food which is not food and no wonder
they're all obese and uh um uh sick and
um uh you know doing so poorly in school
and by the way also depressed ultr
processed food has now been shown in
three separate studies to correlate with
depression in teenagers so what is the
relationship between processed food or
maybe we call it Nova System level 34
foods and depression and other
psychiatric challenges and if you could
you separate out metabolic syndrome from
obesity um in answering that like like
is there something inherently depressing
about carrying excess adapost tissue as
setting aside any kind of aesthetic um
uh stuff you know how people want to
look or are perceived you know just is
there anything bad about carrying a lot
of body fat independent of the metabolic
syndrome for mood and an overall sense
of well-being no I'm really glad you
asked that Andrew we should have
actually covered this earlier um
everyone thinks fat is fat as we've
learned fat is not fat and a fat is not
a fat but um body fat is not body fat
there are three fat Depot and they are
metabolically different the first is the
does this bathing suit make me look fat
fat by the way never answer that
question that's called subcutaneous fat
or big butt fat if you will so here's
the question how many pounds or kilos of
subcutaneous fat do you have to gain
before you become metabolically ill I
have no idea about 10 kilos about 22 lbs
okay why the reason is because that
subcutaneous fat drains into the
systemic
circulation so you have to have a lot of
cyto kindes coming from those
subcutaneous atopos sites to raise the
blood level of cyto kindes to the point
where it starts doing damage at the
level of the liver so fats are releasing
cytoid which are pro-inflammatory
exactly and they're doing that at rest
any fat cell any fat cell okay any fat
cell but if it's going to the systemic
circulation you have a volume of
distribution of six liters so you have
to lose you know you have to have a lot
of cyto kindes to get the concentration
up now just out of fairness to the
fat how many cyto kindes does a muscle
cell release I mean are are we unfairly
picking on adapost tissue because why
would adapost tissue be pro-inflammatory
I mean a single fat
cell I've got a fat cell sitting at you
know on my shoulder someplace right I
mean I'm not zero fat at my shoulder why
would it be pro-inflammatory so in fact
the fat cell itself is not here's what
happens the fat cell has a fat vacu it
has a storage place for this lipid
droplet you stuff it you stuff it you
stuff it the fat vacu gets bigger bigger
bigger the perpen border that
encompasses that fat vacu that it
borders the the the the space ultimately
can't get any bigger and it starts
breaking down when that happens it
spills the grease into the fat cell the
fat cell
dies becomes necrotic that calls macras
is in to clean up the grease and it's
the
macras that release the cyto kindes all
right so in fact the fat cell is not the
problem it's the breakdown of the grease
that lead leads to the maccrage
activation that's the problem but when
you do it in subcutaneous fat it's going
into this 6 L tank and so the
concentration doesn't go up very much
so 10 kilos before you start seeing some
effect fat Depot number
two visceral or big belly
fat now how many pounds or kilos of big
belly fat you have to gain before you
get metabolically ill I don't know but
I'm guessing it's less than 22 pounds
it's way less oh for once I got an
answer right today that's right about
five about five pounds
now question is why number one the
visceral fat does not drain into the
into the systemic circulation it drains
into the portal vein which goes straight
to the liver so you're getting a bigger
load going straight to the liver of cyto
kindes not to the kidney the good thing
about getting an answer wrong folks is
that you never forget the correct answer
that's why I always tell my students
right so I'll never forget that indeed
got it and the question is what made the
visceral fat in the first place was it
calories no it's cortisol it's stress
it's the combination of the sympathetic
nervous system and cortisol and the
reason we know this is because you can
take patients with major depressive
disorder with endogenous depression who
are suicidal who have to be admitted to
the hospital to keep themselves from
killing themselves stick them in a
scanner and they are losing subcutaneous
fat like crazy because they're not
eating but they're gaining visceral fat
because of the high cortisol and the
stress so there's something about the
adrenocorticoid receptors in that area
that just preferentially Depot fat there
when cortisol is high indeed because
that's the metabolically active
fat right and five pounds will do it and
then finally the third fat Depot the
liver now how many pounds of fat can the
liver store
before you become metabolically
ill got to be even less because the
liver is not nearly as large as the sort
of abdominal region half a pound quarter
of a kilo how much does a healthy liver
weigh healthy liver weighs 1500
grams okay okay so you know it's not
very I'm trying to translate quickly to
pound so we're going Metro we're going a
standard so, 1500 G would be 3 lb so you
know basically half a pound okay so not
very
much because that's where the action is
and so when you have fat in your liver
it causes metabolic dysfunction right
away and the question is where did that
fat come from that came from alcohol or
sugar so alcohol and sugar most
metabolically egregious because it
affects the liver directly
stress second most because it affects
the visceral fat and subcutaneous fat
the least important in terms of
metabolic derangement so yes it may not
look good in the bathing suit but from a
metabolic standpoint it is actually the
least important so the question then
becomes all right what are you trying to
fix if you're trying to fix liver fat
it's really easy get rid of the alcohol
in the sugar except of course they're
both addictive will that also liberate
any fat that's already in the liver
absolutely and that's one of the reasons
why intermittent fasting works is
because it gives your liver a chance to
basically
offload what it's already stored that's
one of the things that intermittent
fasting will buy you is a little e uh
less liver fat so that's a good thing
all right now stress on the other hand
as you know and as we've talked about
and as you know you've had um Dr Lissa
apple on your podcast before you know
stress is tough you know trying to
mitigate stress especially in today's
environment and I hope you'll invite me
back sometime to talk about the the role
of stress on um the amydala yeah gladly
okay um and then finally you know
subcutaneous fat so when people go on
diet
sweeteners what are they doing are they
really
reducing the fat and the answer is no
when you're talking about artificial
sweeteners artificial diet sweeteners of
any sort you can pick your artificial
sweetener so a spart tame or you know uh
suc sucos Stevia monk fruit uh um the
new ones you know yeah the one that
people are more excited about nowadays
is alos Al it's expensive it tends to
have less of an artificial sweetener
taste that people can detect right um so
you're saying that regardless of oh and
we should I'm remembering from the
comment section I do read them
artificial sweeteners and
noncaloric sweeteners yes because the
moment you say artificial people say
what about Stevia what about Alo so so
let's just say um uh non-caloric
sweeteners can wrap our arms around all
that entire category sure unless we need
to distinguish among the different
participants in that category so you're
saying that even though people can um
lower their total choric intake pretty
effectively I've seen the studies that
show if you know dieters who consume um
water only as their you know main liquid
versus diet sodas with aspartame
typically or Stevia the diet soda
drinkers actually lose more weight we
know that but you're saying there may be
deposition of fat in the liver in those
individuals be specifically because of
the artificial sweetening because of the
insulin turns out there's still an
insulin response it's a fa very famous
study done in um Copenhagen 100 normal
individuals 25 in four different groups
one
group uh one uh one liter of sugared
soda per day for six months one liter
that's a lot of sugared soda yeah one
group one liter of diet soda per day for
six months I probably did that in
graduate school one group one liter of
milk per day for 6 months I probably did
that when I was an infant and finally
one final group one liter of water per
day for six months I do that now I do
more than that but yeah the one liter of
soda per day in six months gained 10
kilos the sugary soda the sugary soda 10
kilos okay 10 kilos no surprise the one
liter of water per day lost two kilos
also no surprise those were the easy
ones now let's do the ones in the middle
one liter of milk per
day no change presumably that was full
fat milk we're talking about milk full
fat milk yeah they like their their full
fat milk no change why is that they're
taking on an enormous increase in total
caloric intake I'm guessing that there
is a blunted insulin response due to the
fat and the milk and also because
lactose is not a very uh uh Big Driver
of insulin response and because there's
a satiety effect that's like f eat less
yeah it's like food like
food and finally the key the kicker to
the whole thing diet soda the one liter
of dioda what what would you predict
their weight would do more weight loss
than in the water group based on my
understanding of the literature they
gained two kilos wild because they ate
more
well you tell
me why did they gain two kilos if they
were consuming a liter of Da soda which
are zero calories the answer is because
they still generated an insulin response
and that insulin response generated more
hunger more more weight and more hunger
exactly and that's the key so they
didn't gain the 10 kilos they gained two
kilos so it looks better compared to the
sugared uh uh version but it looks like
you know a problem compared to the water
version or even the milk version so
unless you bootstrap calories and hold
that constant you're going to see a
weight gain due to artificial sweetener
in exactly right and that's been shown
50 ways from Sunday at a whole bunch of
different studies so compared to Sugar
yeah it's better but compared to water
it's way worse and the reason is the
insulin response you put something sweet
on the tongue message goes tongue to
brain Sugar's coming message goes brain
to pancreas through the vus nerve
Sugar's coming release the insulin and
so tongue doesn't know if it's sugar or
not it releases the in the pancreas
releases the insulin which drives energy
into fat whether it was you know from
the uh diet sweetener or not I I saw
some really interesting data from Dana
Small's group at Yale showing that when
people have a diet soda with food so
this is like the diet coke with the
sandwich or with the burger maybe even
with the pasta the insulin resp response
from the food and the insulin response
from the diet soda are compounded but
there's a classical conditioning effect
pavlovian effect such that then later if
they just drink the diet soda they get
an even bigger insulin response just to
the diet soda than they would have
originally if they only had the diet
soda separate from food so in other
words the the insulin the food induced
insulin response is conditioning a
greater insulin response from the diet
soda and we actually have another study
that demonstrates the same thing out of
Singapore um teay at all uh in American
Journal clinical nutrition 2018 I
believe that looked at a similar
Paradigm here's what they did they took
a bunch of people and they admitted them
to their Clinical Research Center four
times a week apart and they did them in
random order and each time they uh
started the morning they fasting and
they did either a sucrose tolerance test
or an aspartame tolerance test or a
sucralose tolerance test or a monk fruit
tolerance test so two hours you know
ingesting one of the three one of the
four and measuring glucose and Insulin
over the course of the next two hours
fasted fasted okay okay then it was time
for lunch and they let them have
whatever lunch they want it was a
metabolic Buffet they could eat whatever
they want wanted off the
buffet except that they were being
clocked and the same for dinner they
were being clocked but they could eat
whatever they wanted in a given period
of time in the 24 hours okay you know or
you know from 7:00 a.m. to 7:00 p.m.
whenever they went home okay turned out
the sucrose tolerance test generated an
insulin response as you'd expect the
monk fruit the Ste the uh U sucros and
the aspartame did not but then when they
ate
lunch they if they had had one of the
three diet sweeteners in the morning
they ate more at lunch and more at
dinner and generated an increased
insulin response both at lunch and
dinner so that the area under the curve
for the whole day was exactly the same
so they ate a significantly more yeah
yeah because they had the diet soda in
the
morning Wild Well I
drink drinks that contain Stevia and I
don't worry about it too much but what
you're saying is even if I bootstrap my
calories there's a possibility that the
insulin response could have Direct
effects on the liver exactly right and
not for the better and not for the
better now having said
that um we have undertaken an
interesting project which I don't know
if you know about
um in 2020 during the pandemic I was was
approached by a food company in the
Middle East called Kuwaiti Danish Dairy
company kdd it's the Nestle of the
Middle East now they make all sorts of
junk frozen yogurt flavored milks ice
cream confectionary biscuits tomato
sauce
okay Kuwait has an 18% diabetes rate and
an
80% obesity rate 80 zero wow in the
adults all right now the company
recognized that they wanted to be a
metabolically healthy company and they
knew they
weren't they contacted me and said would
you put together a scientific advisory
team to advise us what we need to do to
change the food in order to be a
metabolically healthy company and we
want to lead and I said we'd be ha I'd
be happy to do that with one Proviso we
get to publish what we did so that it
can serve as a road map for the rest of
the food industry and they said fine and
so I convened a scientific advisory team
with my colleague wol from Alderson who
started the very first farmers market in
Los Angeles and is now actually the
director of sustainability and nutrition
for
kdd um uh Tim Harland who is the head of
culinary medicine at George Washington
University Rachel
who is a fatty acid expert who ran the
omega-3 for add trial at the NIH and
Andreas cornat who's actually a computer
scientist from
Stanford and we
basically stripped down every single
thing that kdd did in terms of
procurement in terms of ingredients in
terms of packaging we submitted every
single ingredient to biochemical
analysis because you couldn't trust what
the vendors were
basically telling kdd was in the food we
had had to actually know what was in the
food and that was a half a million
dollars all by itself I mean this was
not a cheap little uh you know uh you
know sojourn into the woods this was a
big deal we basically
reengineered their entire 180 item
portfolio and they have now turned over
10% of their products to be
metabolically
healthy
and the precepts that were we set in
this paper which is in Frontiers and
nutrition in March of this year
2023 three things three principles if
you adhere to these three principles you
can turn any food healthy including
Ultra processed food number one protect
the liver number two feed the gut number
three support the
brain if you have a food that does all
three of those it is healthy if you have
a food that does none of those three
then it's poison because it's not food
it's I was going to say it doesn't sound
like food is is the right um the right
descriptor in that case exactly and if
it's does one or two but not all three
then it's going to be somewhere in
between so the goal was to take all of
KD's products and move them from you
know the lowest tier up to the highest
tier by adhering to these three
principles and we came up with some very
simple things number one got to get rid
of the sugar number two got to add fiber
number three got to add
Omega-3s number four gotta do something
about the
emulsifiers because the emulsifiers are
causing the gut inflammation because
after all emulsifiers are detergents
they hold fat and water together they
burn a hole in the mucin layer so
they're actually contributing to that
gut inflammation and emulsifiers are you
know stre throughout ultr processed food
them we've heard about hidden sugars a
lot um during today's episode and
elsewhere but based on everything you
told us of about artificial excuse me
low calorie sweeteners um it makes more
sense to me now why foods that are not
touted as diet foods would be laced with
things like sucralose because it should
drive the craving for that food through
increases in insulin and craving of
other Foods later that day and later
that evening is that
why non-caloric sweeteners are added to
to all sorts of foods now that because
typically one things noncaloric
sweeteners probably only added to quote
unquote diet foods low calorie foods but
that's not you're right it's that that's
not the case and they are adding diet
diet sweeteners to foods that you didn't
know had diet sweeteners in them that's
right um there are two reasons that this
happens one is insulin because insulin
blocks leptin signaling at the level of
the hypothalamus and the nucleus
accumbent so if it blocks leptin leptin
is the hormone that your fat cells make
that tells your brain you've had enough
so if insulin blocks leptin it makes you
hungrier and it also extinguishes it it
it stops the extinguishing of reward by
that food so that you want more of it so
it does both because leptin normally
suppresses food intake and reduces
craving the analogy that comes to mind
is um a slot machine that encourages you
to feed more money and hit go to pull
the lever but that also blinds you to
the outcome so even if you win you don't
even know that you have wins it's also
blinding you to your losses you're
effectively becoming automaton yeah of
just eating without any um kind of
conscious understanding of what you're
you're bringing in or tasting the food
any longer exactly right it's not this
like and Anna lmy when she came on the
podcast author of dopamine nation and
obviously head of our dual diagnosis
addiction clinic at Stanford talked
about
you know these these consumptive
behaviors where people are scrolling
social media or consuming porn or uh
consuming drugs or alcohol in a way that
like they're not in touch with the
pleasure of the of the substance or
behavior anymore they become automatons
but they but if they don't do it they
feel lousy so the pleasure is gone the
pain is definitely waiting tolerance and
dependence that's the definition of
addiction so dopamine is an excitatory
neurotransmitter it excites the next
neuron always there was no such thing as
dopamine inhibiting a postoptic neuron
dopamine stimulates the next neuron and
it doesn't matter which dopamine
receptor it is one through five it's
always excitatory now neurons like to be
excited that's why they have receptors
but neurons like to be tickled not
bludgeoned chronic overstimulation of
any neuron and you know this leads to
neuronal cell death and the reason is
because the neuron needs energy the
neuron is the most energy
dependent uh tissue in the body it needs
those mitochondria to be pumping out ATP
like crazy to engage in
neurotransmission well when you're
firing
nonstop you risk cell death so the
excitatory neuron the the poptic neuron
has a plan B it downregulates the
receptor it downregulates the dopamine
receptor so there's less chance that any
stray dopamine molecule will find a
receptor to bind to and this is its Plan
B in order to try to mitigate the risk
of
dying well what does that mean in human
terms it means you get a hit you get a
rush receptors go down next time you
need a bigger hit to get the same rush
and receptors go down and you need a
bigger hit and a bigger hit and a bigger
hit until finally you need a huge hit to
get nothing that's called tolerance and
then when the neurons do start to die
that's called
addiction that's what we've got and
that's what's happened in terms of food
addiction
so the question is what's
addictive is fat addictive no because if
fat was addictive then all the people on
the Atkins diet or on the ketogenic diet
would be gaining weight not losing it
and I'd be craving ribe eyes all day I
like a ribeye pretty often actually but
I know I know people say no but hey look
my lipids are in in line and I I don't
eat many starches and I certainly avoid
sugar although now I'm thinking I might
want to really reduce my uh low calorie
sweetener intake I don't see myself
reducing my Stevia intake to zero
because it's in some things I really
like Andrew I am not the food police um
you know I always say that to people I'm
not a cop but the um but but but data
are data and and and Health Data are the
the the data say that that's not helping
you any that's what the data say mhm um
point is that the Fat's not the problem
the salt's not the problem the
caffeine's a problem really caffeine's
classic addictive substance at every
level yeah but in Sugar's a problem but
if if one can cut out caffeine by the
early afternoon or even sooner in the
day and it's not consumed to excess um
and it's in the form or coffee or bate
some other form that's healthy you know
is it really that much of a problem um I
love coffee in your that's my addiction
like with a capital l underline bold
face highlight I I I I I feel your pain
and the answer is no one has shown that
coffee is toxic it is addictive but it's
not toxic now if you mix the coffee with
alcohol now you got four Loco now it's
toxic but in and of itself caffeine is
not um toxic and that's why there's a
Starbucks on every street corner but it
is highly reinforcing I did an episode
on caffeine where um it covered some
data that was published in the journal
science one of the three Apex journals
um and if you put caffeine unbeknown to
the consumer into plain yogurt people
will crave plain yogurt indeed much more
I mean people like the feeling of being
caffein as long as it's not creating
anxiety levels of energy exactly to
stick with caffeine that's fine yeah and
so will I we've been talking a little
bit about the hypothalamus as well as
some peripheral gut-based mechanisms for
hunger and satiety right um this is a
great opportunity to talk about some of
the glp1 agonists that are now
um widely used so things typically
called those zic but gp1 gluc glucon
likee peptide one right um originally
discovered in the heila monster which
eats very seldom and some really smart
biologist I love biology like this said
how come they don't have to eat very
much well they their blood is loaded
with gp1 right um and so they only have
to eat one Whatever helila monsters um
Delight in per year or something
outrageous like that humans make glp1 as
well my understanding is that gp1 that
that not that's injected but that one um
makes
naturally is acting on both the brain
and the gut to increase satiety so it is
acting on the brain no argument but the
primary action is on the
gut gp1 decreases the rate of gastric
emptying that is its primary driver yes
it does affect the brain I'm not arguing
that it does but the primary effect is
to reduce the rate of gastric emptying
so you stay Fuller longer because the
food doesn't move through the stomach
and the intestine interesting in South
America in uguay in Argentina it was
long thought that um yeram mate
consumption which we know very modestly
increases glp and by the way a lot of
other things do too um that people were
taking it for its uh after meals for its
laxative effect partially that's you
know it's not pleasant for but that's
also at the colon that's at the level of
rather the stomach but it is used fairly
effectively for people to space their
meals without snacking that you're you
know and maybe it's the glp1 maybe it's
something else um but people are
injecting themselves with gp1 analoges
now $1,300 a month is that what it cost
that's what it lost right um and it
seems to be pretty effective at inducing
weight loss although a significant
amount of that weight loss seems to be
from a skeletal muscle tissue and we're
g we need to talk about that so what are
your thoughts on OIC as a as a primary
uh earlier you talked about primary and
secondary control you referred to it a
little bit differently in the context of
statins right um so a kid comes in who's
obese or slightly overweight it's like I
don't know what to do I'm trying to eat
better exercise or a person comes in and
says hey i' I've had a really hard time
getting that last 20 uh n pounds off for
so many years will you prescribe me
those mic so the short answer is number
one I'm retired so I'm not prescribing
anything but let's let's let's go with
there the data show that gp1 analoges
like um semaglutide and now tepati which
is uh Li version uh Manjaro is the
diabetes version Zep bound is the
Obesity version in the same way that OIC
is the diabetes version for um uh
novonordisk and wovi is the Obesity
version so they're all glp1 they're all
GP gp1 analog there synthesized in a lab
it looks like gp1 smells like gp1 acts
like gp1 when injected tepati the uh
Lily one actually has a dual function it
uh binds to the
Gip recept receptor so it might have
double duty and the data show that it's
actually even slightly more effective at
Weight Loss than the Nova Nordisk
version so we'll be seeing a shift in
terms of uh uh consumer preference soon
no doubt but here's the thing you look
at the data one year uh of treatment 16%
weight loss now that sounds great and
I'm not saying it's bad it's good and
people are not craving food all the time
is that because people are feeling full
longer right so they're eating less
they're eating less this is the calorie
in calorie out model they're eating less
and so they are losing weight I'm not
arguing that and they might be craving
alcohol less According to some recent
reports yeah well we can go there for a
minute too in a
second here's the problem when you look
at that 16% weight loss as you just said
when you put people in a dexas scanner
they have lost equal amounts of fat and
muscle musle now is it good to lose
muscle no it is not good ask any little
old lady who breaks her hip if she wish
she had a little bit more muscle or
somebody who dieted lost a lot of muscle
because they weren't offsetting the
weight loss with resistance training or
some other form of exercise and the
amount of food that they can eat in
order to maintain that weight to put it
in scientific terms sucks and um you
know we mentioned Peter AA earlier okay
in outlive he's made it very clear that
sarcopenia lack of muscle mass is one of
the drivers of mortality so losing
muscle is not uh uh a a good idea but
you lose equal amounts of fat and muscle
what else causes loss of equal amounts
of fat and muscle starvation in fact the
reason that all these glp1 analogues
work is because you stop eating like the
he yeah just like the Heil monster the
Heil monsters look pretty chubby to me
well
ask another heal a monster I did but
unfortunately whatever answer it
provided was not interpretable indeed
the point is that starvation is not so
good and if you think about why it's
working it's reducing gastric the rate
of gastric emptying all right well it
turns out that that's the reason for its
side effects the reduction in gastric
emptying that's why you get nausea
that's why you get vomiting that's why
you get pain
pancreatitis and most importantly now
gastroparesis your stomach turns to
Stone and you can't move any food
through your intestine at all and worse
yet when you stop the medicine the
gastroparesis doesn't get better this is
not a good idea this is like the
opposite of the yerbamate induced effect
which has a sort of prolax gastri
emptying Maybe glp1 agonism gosh okay so
it's obvious why people who've struggled
to lose weight like it especially if
they're struggled to lose weight was at
least in their mind the consequence of
being hungry all the time and needing to
eat more or was it because of the reward
and you know their
dependence because in fact yes uh uh uh
these go1 analoges reduce reward and
that's one of the reasons why they've
noticed that you know thing uh uh
reduction in alcohol consumption uh as
well and that sounds like a good thing
except there also numerous cases now of
major depressive disorder in response to
these drugs so it's almost like an Al
treone or something for the treatment of
addiction which sometimes can be useful
but now but the attempting to remove the
the um the amplitude of that reward
signal I mean a lot on paper it makes
sense but the but it doesn't always play
and in practice it doesn't play out
that's right and so I'm going to refer
you now to an old uh literature that uh
was from 2006 there was a drug that was
approved in Europe called
raniban okay a trade name ACC complia
and it was approved in uh Europe for
weight loss and it was pretty good at
Weight Loss it caused about 20% weight
loss it also caused severe depression
and 21 suicides
so it's no longer available because it
was the an yeah it was pulled from the
European market never approved in the
United States and the reason this
happened was because this was the
anti-marijuana drug this was the anti-
munchies drug this was an endoc canabo
antagonist well when you reduce reward
you also reduce your desire to live and
that's why this concern about reduction
in alcohol consumption we've already
seen major depressive disorder in
patients receiving OIC so are we going
to see the same thing play out as we did
for rabant I'm worried about it or
fenfen well fenfen didn't have um uh no
it was cardiac it was cardiac right we
had cardiac problems due to the
fenfluramine because of the uh serotonin
1B receptor agonism right I'm just
referring to the fact that these these
quote unquote Blockbuster drugs for
obesity they tend to follow a contour of
you know very prom ing very exciting a
lot of people losing
weight suicides or very promising a lot
of people losing
weight um cardiac issues very promising
losing weight and now you're saying the
stomach turns to Stone sound sounds so
biblical uh well indeed so that's the
question and then finally we can really
talk biblical if everyone in America who
qualified for OIC got it that would be
2.1 trillion to the healthc care system
which is currently at 4.1 trillion so
that would be a greater than 50%
increase in health care
costs okay at300 a
month
conversely if we just got sugar
consumption down to USDA guidelines by
basically you know putting some limits
on how much added sugar the food
industry can put into any given product
like Froot
Loops we could reduce weight by
29% and save $3.0 trillion doar so we'd
get better weight loss and we'd save
$5.1
trillion which makes more sense to the
US
government well earlier you were
alluding to government uh big food big
Pharma relationships I mean there's a
huge win here for whoever's
manufacturing these um gp1 analoges
indeed um but the question is who's
paying the tab well we are um um now the
question is why can't the government see
that and the answer is because the
government's on the Dole too because the
government uh uh through tariffs on
us-made Foods okay grosses um 56 billion
a
year so they're a player they're not
just a regulator they're an actor to
play devil Devil's Advocate a little bit
listen I'm going to be the last person
to step in and try and defend government
as a as a unified body I'm not qualified
to do that but you could see how it if
you looked at it like Checkers instead
of Chess you'd say okay here's a drug
that's going to allow many millions of
people to reduce their overall body
weight overall body weight is a risk
factor for a number of things um and
there will be savings on the back end as
a consequence of that weight loss I mean
so that's the checkers version right the
chess version is how you're describing
it and I think that um I mean
clearly people in government are are
well most some perhaps are smart enough
to play chess not Checkers or to at
least understand it but there's very
little incentive for the chess model so
um what would quote unquote solve this
problem is the same thing that happened
to fenfen or this Ro Roman which is if
suddenly there's a major issue with the
drug then everyone stops taking it and
traditionally that's how it's gone it
sounds like these gp1 analoges are going
to make it through the shoes though yeah
I
mean there is a very clear downside to
these medicines on the other hand you
know there's an upside and so I'm not
sad that these medicines exist I'm for
them I'm not against them I'm for them
for the right patient and right now it's
not the right patient who's getting them
just like the statens so what if
somebody who's taking uh one of these
analoges makes it a point to do
resistance training and here you know
you mentioned bodybuilders earli I'm not
I'm not suggesting they become
bodybuilders but we now know and I think
petera and others would agree that
everybody should be doing some form of
muscle loss offsetting resistance
exercise agree at least past you know
their reaching their adult height or
something you know I know there are
those that say weight training doesn't
blunt your height but anyway let's just
say that from early 20s onward doing
especially especially if you're on these
medicines right in order to maintain
muscle mass right so that's a different
picture
right um people are drinking less
alcohol again I'm playing devil's
advocate here um so if we look at these
these compounds not in a vacuum but okay
the person who's been carrying that
extra 30 pounds is now only carrying a
few extra pounds of adapost tissue
they've lost a lot of muscle but now
they feel well enough to exercise um the
depression part worries me yeah but
anyway I'm just I'm just trying to round
the Contour of it what we've seen in
children you know because that's who I
took care of was was that often they
needed a jump start okay and there were
different ways to get them to jump start
stomach stapling well that's not jump
start that's but that was what a lot of
people did I know I have a friend he's
he was and sadly still is really big and
he always talked about the stomach
saving like if I could just get 50
pounds down quickly then I could
exercise but exercise is painful this
kind of thing and and sadly he's he's
continued to maintain or creep up in in
a very excessive weight and that's the
point is you know that this concept of
jump start actually if if you're only
doing it yourself doesn't really work
and the question is why is his weight
creeping up if he's had the stomach
stapling the answer is because he's a
sugar addict yeah he's definitely
addicted to the super big gulp soda and
if you drink your calories it doesn't
really matter does it no and and he's
got such terrible psoriasis and joint
pain and all this that the prospect of
exercising is like a you might as well
tell him to to like flap his wings and
go to Mars you know fructose is a driver
of immune dysfunction if he got off you
can tell him from me if he got off the
sugar his psoriasis would get better his
weight would get better his arthritis
would get better and he could have then
that jump start this is a perfect
example to bridge to the brain component
of all this because I've long wondered
based on what I understand about neural
circuitry and
neuroplasticity I know we share in this
knowledge that at some point carrying a
lot of adapost tissue means that the
brain sort of represents the body
differently I mean we know there are
these these somatotopic M maps of self
um you know but that the neural
Machinery in the hypothalamus sure which
is responsible for Motivated States Etc
but but also just the entire mapping of
the self yeah changes in other words if
one is fat long enough mhm that it
becomes increasing ly hard to get to a
healthy weight because of the way that
the neural circuitry is impacted it
basically remaps to maintain that that
um fat person not necessarily even just
at the level of appetite but just in
terms of what do you what do big animals
do I had a bulldog that weigh 90 lb
Bulldog Mastiff he was very economical
with his movement right he was extremely
powerful he could run at least in when
he was younger but if he could be still
he was still as opposed to certain
smaller animals that are like peretic
right because because he was leptin
resistant so leptin as we talked about
briefly is um the hormone that tells
your brain you've had enough if you are
leptin sensitive you are happy to burn
if you are LEP and resistant your brain
thinks you're starving and if your brain
thinks you're starving it's going to
affect your behavior in two ways it's
going to make you want to eat and it's
also going to make you want to conserve
because the goal is to try to increase
the leptin levels in order to overcome
that resistance which of course you can
never do because all you're going to do
is lay down more fat and make more
leptin that makes so much sense because
leptin comes from the adapost tissue
exactly so that leptin resistance is
what you have to be able to break
through you have to fix the leptin
sensitivity well what's the driver of
the leptin resistance
insulin insulin inhibits leptin
signaling and it does it at three
separate places in the palc neuron the
proopiomelanocortin neuron in the
hypothalamus it does it at um irs2
insulin receptor substrate 2 it does it
at socks 3 suppressor of cyto signaling
3 and it does it at pip 3 phosphole
andosol triphosphate those three
separate arms of the uh uh leptin
receptor are all basically put to sleep
by high insulin insulin blocks Le in
signaling so the higher the insulin goes
the more your brain thinks you're
starving and the more your brain thinks
you're starving the hungrier you get and
the less you want to move so the
gluttony and sloth that we've been
talking about all all you know podcast
is really biochemical it is secondary to
this phenomenon of insulin blocking
leptin signaling you got to fix that
first get the insulin in down any way
you can and the best way get rid of the
refined carbohydrate and
sugar that's where you
start it makes so much sense it works
too how about that that's always good it
is I once heard you say I think it was
in a conversation with Peter AA on his
podcast and this really stuck in my mind
that when a person
consumes
glucose that it activates a number of
different brain sites you know neurons
loving glucose but that when one ingests
fructose that it preferentially
activates neurons in the reward pathway
that's right at maybe seven times the
the magnitude or or something like that
well uh glucose activates the basil
ganglia uh this is work from walner
Housen and uh Switzerland and also Eric
stce at or for movement at planning and
execution exactly okay um fructose
basically stimulates the nucleus
accumbent the reward center it is just
like heroin Just Like Cocaine just like
uh nicotine it activates the reward
center it doesn't do anything for the
basil
ganglia so it is addictive anything that
stimulates the reward center in the
extreme is addictive so we have chemical
addictions heroin cocaine nicotine
alcohol sugar we have behavioral
addictions shopping gambling internet
gaming social media pornography doesn't
matter they all stimulate dopamine in
the reward center and in the extreme
they are all addictive so the question
is if you are
addicted is that personal
responsibility well it's uh a very
um it's a question I think about a lot
because uh I know a lot of people in the
addiction recovery Community um both
from the treatment end and the addict
end yeah and there's always comes down
to this question when somebody is
suffering from an addiction of any kind
and they're resistant to getting
treatment if you look at it them as a as
being sick at least in that moment is a
sick person in the best or worst or at
least diminished position to guide their
own treatment so for instance somebody
with dementia would you ask them do you
want to go see a
neurologist you might ask them that but
are they the best person to make that
that decision well this is the problem
so that this is this is where personal
responsibility falls down so personal
responsibility as you know we talked
about four criteria have to be met none
of them are met that's the first issue
second one is a little bit shall we say
cheek gear who invented personal
responsibility any idea I'm definitely
going to get this this one wrong yeah
you're going to get this one wrong are
you ready got yeah I don't know the
tobacco industry the notion of person Al
responsibility they invented it there
was no personal responsibility until
tobacco in 1962 CU they were getting
killed on the science and they needed to
invent another reason for you to smoke
in fact there's a paper that came out
Dorfman at all that looked at the New
York Times And The Washington Post and
they did a entire lit search of the
entire of uh you know the all of the
output of those two new newspapers for
decades to look for the term personal
responsibility and the very first time
it was ever mentioned was
1962 and it didn't pick up in speed
until
1986 which was the same year as cipolone
V liot in the at the Supreme Court which
basically said that the uh you know that
uh uh the cigarette industry was um was
guilty of U of um uh applying people
with an addictive substance so this is
very
specifically industry-driven and we have
the data to prove it amazing
well I
wonder along the lines of personal
responsibility um given that many
listeners to this conversation are going
to be thinking about their own food
intake and food choices that of their
children and other relatives that we
could play a little a little uh not a
game but a little rapid is fire Q&A
never done this before in this podcast
but I think it's particularly
appropriate for a discussion like this
that Wicks out into so many areas and I
absolutely will invite you back and
perhaps along with um lle to talk about
some of the exciting work you guys are
doing because there's so much we could
cover but people are going to wonder in
a very practical
sense whether or not they should or
should not be consuming certain things
and I know you're not the food police
I'm not the food police and I'm not a
cop and I do believe people should are
should be in choice about these matters
but I also believe that because you're a
guest on the podcast and you're highly
informed and and have done clinical work
and research for so many years in this
area and you have such a clear stance on
the role of big food and and we really
really appreciate your your honesty and
directness but not you'd be willing to
provide a comment about a couple of
different terms that I'll throw out and
if you choose to say really nothing to
say about that fine that would be a
quick Quick Pass so um here we go um and
we covered a little bit of this earlier
but um fruit in whole form so
um has fructose but has fiber so thumbs
up thumbs sideways or thumbs down for
fruit consumption fruit is fine fruit
juice is not great thank you white rice
versus brown rice and among the white
rice is the sticky rice um and the Rices
with added sugars which you find in in a
lot of um a lot restaurants brown rice
because of the fiber white rice polished
you know number one all the vitamin B1
gone and of course a much larger glucose
Excursion that glycemic index thing
which of course I hate is it's glycemic
load that matters and that is a very
high glycemic load so brown rice so
brown rice is better than white rice yes
okay in a meaningful way in a meaningful
way okay um earlier you mentioned tomato
sauce I love tomato sauce that's made
from just Tomatoes can Tom so is are
most tomato sauces filled with sugar
perfect our little uh recommendation
engine looked at this question and it
turns out that only 10% of the available
tomato sauces out on the market don't
have added sugar so you have to know
which ones well you can look yourself or
you can look up perfect and it will tell
you which ones you can buy if people
chose to consume bread which many people
do uh is there a way to just across the
board without just baking your own or
see or looking at the ingredients list
to make a better choice is it like
sourdoughs tend to have less sugar than
blank um well sourdough has been
fermented so it will have actually
consumed some of the sugar so it would
be a better choice but really the best
choice is the highest fiber breads
now if you look at a wheat berry
it is
25% fiber the husk is 25% of the weight
of that wheat berry that means that the
carbohydrate to fiber ratio of a wheat
berry is
3:1 so a good bread should have a
carbohydrate to fiber ratio of somewhere
between 3:1 to 5:1 tops anything above
that means that they've stripped the
fiber away so that's something you could
do but the easier way is to actually
look it up on
perfect you mentioned meat and meat
sourcing um egg and chicken sourcing
earlier maybe we just revisit that um
meat fish and eggs uh thumbs up thumbs
sideways thumbs down or it depends it
depends it depends on where the meat
came from it depends on whether it was
pastur raised depends on whether it's
organic or not if they uh animal was
injected with antibiotics stay away from
it because those antibiotics are in the
meat they're going to to basically
sterilize your gut and then the bad
bacteria are going to take over we
haven't really talked much about the
microbiome today but that's a whole
podcast all by itself well we can touch
on it a little bit more uh F low sugar
fermented foods thumbs up thumbs
sideways thumbs fermented foods short
chain fatty acids all good what are your
favorite sources of fermented foods I
like kimchi yeah I like kimchi too I
like some of the live sourkrauts yeah
that's also good but with the right you
know the right uh AC accouterment um the
one thing I would be uh careful about is
yogurt okay so there are yogurts with
live cultures and there are a whole lot
of yogurts with dead cultures and if
it's a yogurt with dead cultures it's
kind of irrelevant and the chances are
they've actually covered up the sourness
with sugar so Comm you know large
commercially available yogurt be very
very careful okay if it's a you know
Artisan yogurt you know made by a you
know people you know or trust you know
that's a very different story um you
know yogurts with live cultures
intermittent fasting do you practice it
and what do you think about it um I
don't practice it but I am for it for
the right patient turns out who's the
right patient the patient with liver fat
because the reason it works is because
it gives the liver a chance to basically
burn off the fat that it's stored
zero calorie
soda got it it's definite no and I don't
even have to ask about sugary soda
because that's uh that that's basically
just poison in a can food combinations
uh I have a feeling I know what your
answer is but the glycemic index which
we know your feelings on now um asserts
that if you combine some fat with a
sugary like like eating ice cream you
have a more blunted insulin response
than if you were to eat pure sugar of
equivalent calories but um
what are your thoughts on food
combinations as a way to blunt the
insulin response food combinations are
great if there's some Fiber associated
with it it comes back to fiber again and
by the way and by the way uh I you know
full disclosure I am the chief medical
officer of a fiber company what is it it
is called
biolumin and it is a proprietary fiber
it is a uh microcellulose
sponge seven microns in diameter so the
size of a red blood cell you swallow it
it goes to your stomach it expands 70
fold over its original size and so it'll
give you a feeling of fullness because
it's taking up space in the stomach but
more importantly when it expands the
nooks and the crannies in the sponge
become available and embedded in those
nooks and crannies are a set of
propretary hydrogels soluble fiber which
sequester glucose fructose sucrose
simple starch es and render them
unavailable for early absorption in the
dadum thus reducing the glucose response
reducing the insulin response protecting
the liver and moving it through the
intestine so that microbiome can chew it
up for its own purposes feeding the gut
we can reduce glucose absorption by 36%
fructose absorption by 38% sucrose
absorption by 40% simple starch
absorption by 9% and increased short
chain fatty A acid production by
60% without an increase in gas when do
people take this with meals okay so B it
it comes as a sachche u one teaspoon
sprinkle it on your food or take it as a
you know in a drink you know just mix it
in and Slug it down and then eat
breakfast lunch or dinner and it will
basically act like you ate real food it
will turn processed food into real food
in the intestine and we have clinical
trial data that demonstrates that is it
available as a commercial it is
available it is called Munch Munch now I
hate that name I didn't make it up well
you getet yeah your marketing team sucks
but the product sounds amazing um so
biol. Tech great thank you for that
sorry Munch Munch marketing team but you
got to munch munch to a new product name
um but it sounds like a a very
interesting product and it actually
answered my next question which was
about um fiber supplements fiber is good
but there are two kinds of fiber there's
soluble and there's insoluble they are
not the same so soluble is what goes
into Fiber One bars you know that
psyllium um
inulin uh um uh uh pectin like what
holds jelly together um that's good I'm
not saying it's bad but you need the
insoluble fiber the cellulose the
stringy stuff in celery the cardboard if
you will um together they form this gel
that we talked about earlier if you only
consume the soluble fiber which is what
the food industry will add to to food
because the insoluble fiber is not
missible if you only add the soluble
fiber back you're not getting the
benefits of the entire fiber
complement earlier when talking about
the Nova system and uh how most all of
our food so n let's say I know it was 7
to 10% let's say 95% let's air on the
side of better uh 95% of our food should
come from Nova System class one or class
two Foods or three or three okay staying
away from those um Nova class 4 Foods
could you give us some examples of Nova
class one and Class 2 Foods um just BR
broadly speaking okay Nova class one is
any food without a
label
period if you see a label on a food it's
a warning label well there's ground
ground beef has a label okay so that's
well does it so you're talking about
Apple well when I buy it it has a label
I'm asking this because people are going
to wonder so well it doesn't have a
nutrition facts label is there a
nutrition facts label on a thing of
ground beef I buy that that uh ground
beef where I consume venison um where if
you flip it over it says how many
calories how many protein so there's a
label um but but it's just beef for
venison okay then that's class one okay
egg egg is class one so and then of
course fruit apples orange okay so it
doesn't matter if it has a has a name a
name tag as long as it it doesn't have
an ingredient lab got it real food does
not need a label it's only if they did
something to it that it needs a label so
you have to look at every label as a
warning label now the problem with the
label is it only tells you what's in the
food what you really need to know is
what's been done to the food because
it's the ultr processed food that's the
problem they don't want to tell you that
that's secret okay secret from a
proprietary standpoint but also secret
because if you knew what they did to it
you wouldn't need it you would never buy
it and they don't want you to know so
they only tell you what's in the food
that's not what's important it's what's
been done to the food that's important
and that's why this Nova class 4 is so
important and that's why perfect is so
important because it'll do the work for
you okay well definitely um provide
links to all of these
so if you could pick one thing to
recommend to people that want to improve
their health get rid of the sugar okay
period very clear that's number one
number two go for a walk the exercise
piece yeah go for a walk and if you
could recommend one thing that the
general public can do to try and um
assist in this advocacy
for not redefining but actually clearly
defining what is food and what isn't and
making people aware um at the level of
policy and change and school lunches I
mean if there were one thing what can we
do I mean I I you've clearly activated
my neurons surrounding like the the the
set of problems that exist and the paths
to correct them but should we be writing
to our Congress people should we be um
getting angry at hospitals because
they've got all these fast food machines
and that the cafeteria food is like is
like is like illness promoting at UCSF
we've gotten rid of oil sugar beverages
we have the healthy beverage initiative
so no Coke machines at UC No Coke
machines at ucss wow Stanford check that
out because you know people always send
me pictures of the of the coke machines
in the school of medicine I'm like
listen I didn't put him there but I I I
uh we have to model for the public you
know I mean where where was the first
place that smoking was banned hospitals
okay because we knew so if you get rid
of the you know uh uh soda if you get
rid of the sugared soda at the hospital
you're telling people something so yeah
I think that every hospital and really
every public venue in America needs to
clear out the junk so post photos of
junk that are supposed to be in uh in
health promoting institutions and um I
guess the we're trying to cancel junk
food we're trying to cancel junk food
I'm pretty opposed to cancel culture but
here we go we're going to cancel um
marvelous it's actionable it's
straightforward it's low cost low time
investment zero cost um very low time
investment so thank you for that and
look up eat real because we're doing it
for your kids so you need to help
support it any school district in
America can do it so what do we do we
have a business model whereby the uh
Food Services director um either
purchases or rents a dilapidated Factory
in the center of the district repurposes
it into a food preparation facility they
can make 27 to 30,000 meals a day okay
with a you know Skeleton Crew and then
they and and you control what's in it
and because you're buying in volume it
actually reduces the cost so it's
cheaper than buying it from Cisco or
aromar or sedexo or wherever and then
you farm it out via you know truck or
bus all the different schools so every
kid gets a hot meal made from scratch
each day and we can solve
this
problem can't help but ask this one last
question for people that want to cut out
sugar which you clearly stated is the
most important thing to do for one's
Health how do we know how much sugar is
in something I so should people be
looking at labels and just looking for
how how much sugar how much carbohydrate
or could we even go so far as to say if
it says um high fructose corn syrup then
it's it's on the nfly list don't don't
don't eat it so the problem the problem
is that there are 262 names for sugar
and the food industry uses all of them
and the reason they use all of them is
because they can include a different
sugar as number five number six number
seven number eight number nine on the
list when you add it up it becomes
number one they hide in plain sight and
they do it on
purpose
now do I expect everybody to memorize
all 262 names no of course
not can you figure it out yourself well
the answer is no unless they have the
line where it says added sugars if it
says added sugars it is either sucros or
high fructose corn syrup no one's adding
lactose okay that's not Happ or glucose
they're not even adding adding glucose
because glucose isn't that sweet glucose
is not that interesting you don't see
people going around chugging Kos syrup
do you okay that's glucose who cares
yeah might be good in the Molasses
cookie but that's it all right so it's
fructose so you need to know what's been
added so if it says added sugars that's
a good place to start no greater than
one teaspoon per serving no greater than
four gam per serving of added sugars
anything greater than that leave at the
store and aim for those Nova type type
one for no aim for Nova types one two
and three and if you don't know whether
it's Nova type one two or three you can
use perfect and if you don't look at
that then go look at the nutrition facts
label and anything that has more than
four ingredients is Nova class 4 Robert
lustig thank you so much you've provided
such an incredible educ education in
nutritional biochemistry the processing
of fat protein carbohydrate sugar
fructose in particular the clear
detriments of consuming fructose on so
many different organ systems I love love
love that you separated out food science
Nutrition and
metabolic health or self that's just I
that's a you know that's a gazillion
dollar delineation for people to
understand and to shape their
understanding of all the information
that's out there
and bins into these different categories
you've given us so many actionable tools
um new conceptual Frameworks you given
us a real tour to force today in a just
oh so clear language so I want to thank
you I've learned a ton and um and I know
everyone else has as well and if people
have questions they can of course put
them in the comment section on YouTube
that's the best place we'll provide
links to all the the companies and uh
websit ites that that you referenced and
some of your other work and listen I
just I'm so so grateful that you exist
and that you've done the work that
you've done and and your passion and
your advocacy for health is um it's just
oh so clear so thank you so much for so
I want I want to thank you and the
reason I want to thank you is first of
all you know inviting me that's nice you
know that's good but the reason is
because people need to understand
science I am completely in agreement
with you the public needs to understand
science they listen to you because you
number one provide the science and
number two you don't talk down to them
you treat them as equals and that is
truly remarkable and so I want to thank
you for your service well you're most
welcome it's a labor of love and um I
think it was the great Max Del Brook
that said uh when teaching assume zero
knowledge and infinite intelligence and
I do believe that humans are infinitely
intelligent although sometimes as a
whole we mask it um people deserve the
the knowledge so thank you so much for
sharing that knowledge today and let's
absolutely have you back my pleasure
thank you thank you for joining me for
today's discussion with Dr Robert lustig
about nutrition and how sugar impacts
the health of our brain and body to
learn more about Dr lustig's work and to
find links to the many books that he's
written on this and other topics please
see the show note captions if you're
learning from Andor join this podcast
please subscribe to our YouTube channel
that's a terrific zeroc cost way to
support us in addition please subscribe
to the podcast on both Spotify and apple
and on both Spotify and apple you can
leave us up to a five-star review if you
have questions for me or comments about
the podcast or guess you'd like me to
consider on the hubman Lab podcast
please put those in the comment section
on YouTube I do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not so
much on today's episode but on many
previous episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for improving Focus to learn more about
the supplements discussed on the hubman
Lab podcast go to live momentus spelled
o so Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am huberman lab on
Instagram X formerly called Twitter
LinkedIn Facebook and threads and at all
of those places I discuss science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the hubman
Lab podcast but much of which is
distinct from the content covered on the
huberman Lab podcast so again it's
huberman lab on all social media
channels if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter our neural network newsletter
is a zeroc cost newsletter that comes
out every month it includes podcast
summaries as well as protocols in the
form of short PDFs of maybe just one to
three pages where I list out the
specific protocols for for instance for
improving dopamine functioning or for
improving your sleep or for deliberate
cold exposure deliberate heat exposure
or Fitness protocols and on and on all
of which are presented in brief fashion
very direct just the protocols listed
out again completely zero cost to sign
up you simply go to huberman lab.com go
to the menu function scroll down to
newsletter and enter your email and I
should point out that we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr Robert itic and last
but certainly not least thank you for
your interest in
[Music]
science